bonjour bonjour à tous très heureux de
vous retrouver comme chaque semaine pour
l'événement du mercredi au sénat les
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
dans une heure à 15 heures précises les
sénateurs vont interpeller l'exécutif
une heure des changes direct que vous
allez pouvoir suivre qu'on va commenter
avec notre équipe de journalistes avec
un style jourdain qui se trouve avec
nous dans l'hémicycle style on va parler
pandémie cet après midi mais sous
certains angles école à la maison saison
2 tout devait être prêt pour
l'enseignement à distance généralisée
depuis hier ça bien c'est la théorie
c'était sans compter sur les très
nombreux bugs informatiques du coup et
bien les sénateurs vont interpeller le
gouvernement à ce sujet et puis sera
aussi question de l'avenir du secteur
aérien
aujourd'hui tout est bien on a hâte
steve à tout à l'heure avec nous
également alexandre poussard pour
recueillir à chaud toutes les réactions
des ministres et des sénateurs vous
trouvez salle des conférences alexandre
bonjour tu as mais oui eh bien hier soir
les sénateurs dans l'examen du projet de
loi séparatisme les sénateurs ont voulu
renforcer la neutralité religieuse à
l'université on en parlera avec le
rapporteur du projet de loi au sénat
stéphane pieds noirs à tout al'air
alexandre et enfin comme chaque semaine
on a le plaisir d'être avec jean massiet
gens qui commentent avec sa communauté
sur la plateforme twitch cette séance
dans le cadre de senna stream hewitt
amont à devoir les questions que vous
posez les sénateurs et les sénatrices
sachant que beaucoup d'internautes tu
t'en doutes sont coincés à la maison à
cause des restrictions l'éducation
nationale avec les bugs informatiques
qu'on connaît donc on verra comment sera
traité et ben on va en tout cas déjà en
parler dans cette émission puisque dans
une demi-heure ça sera notre face à face
le sénateur la république en revanche
xavier iacovelli face à jacques
grosperrin sénateurs les républicains on
va revenir sur les débuts chaotiques
lierre de l'école à la maison si les
profs et les élèves sont apparus plutôt
bien rodé un an après le premier
confinement les outils numériques ont
reconnu hier un gros plantage provoqué
l'exaspération des enseignants des
parents des enfants l'école est elle
prête pour le 3e confinement on en parle
à 14h30
mais d'abord le sénat poursuit l'examen
du projet de loi sur le séparatisme on
se penche tout cet après-midi sur la
question du financement des cultes
le texte du gouvernement veut accroître
les obligations des cultes en matière de
transparence financière
c'est une source de tension entre
l'exécutif et les représentants des
religions
on en parle avec jacqueline eustache
brinio bon jour en jour vous êtes
sénatrice les républicains du val d'oise
co rapporteur du projet de loi
confortant le respect des principes de
la république avec nous esther benbassa
bonjour un jour sénatrice écologiste de
paris vice présidente de votre groupe
avec nous également prisca thévenot vous
êtes porte-parole de la république en
marche et nous sommes enfin avec hassen
chalghoumi imam de drancy merci beaucoup
à tous les quatre d'entre eux meurent
pour ce débat d'abord retour sur les
dispositions prévues par le projet de
loi pour obliger les cultes a indiqué
l'origine de leurs ressources
marion delpech sénateurs poursuivent
aujourd'hui l'examen du projet de loi
contre le séparatisme la polémique
soulevée par le financement du chantier
d'une mosquée par la municipalité verte
de strasbourg pourrait s'inviter dans
les échanges
le vote par le conseil municipal de la
ville le 22 mars dernier du principe
d'une subvention de 2,5 millions d'euros
pour la construction de cette mosquée
avait déclenché la colère du ministre de
l'intérieur
heureusement qu'à loi dite séparatisme
arrive parce que ça se sera plus
possible demain grâce à la loi proposée
par le président de la république
demain nous pourrons connaître bien en
amont les financements étrangers sur
notre sol
nous y opposer c'est très important et
puis nous pourrons sur tout et ça c'est
un point très important nous opposer à
la vente de lieux cultuels à l'étranger
et notamment à des pays comme la turquie
en alsace et en moselle l'église et
l'état ne sont pas séparés du fait du
concordat le droit local autorise les
collectivités à financer la construction
d'édifices religieux mais concernant le
reste du territoire
le projet de loi entend mieux encadrer
le financement des lieux de culte en les
incitant à s'inscrire sous le régime de
1905 pour davantage de transparence sur
le plan financier en contrepartie
pourront bénéficier de déductions
fiscales ou de revenus plafonnés
d'immeubles acquis à titre gratuit dans
le projet de loi figurent également
l'obligation de déclarer tout ali nation
dans le lieu de culte français à un état
étranger ainsi que l'obligation de
déclarer les financements étrangers de
plus de 10000 euros par an une
disposition anti putsch est prévu pour
éviter toute prise de contrôle d'une
mosquée par des extrémistes enfin
l'article 44 instaure une procédure de
fermeture pour deux mois des lieux de
culte théâtre de propos idées ou théorie
incitant à la haine et la violence alors
le projet de loi sur le séparatisme pour
objectif de mieux contrôler les
associations qui finance les
établissements religieux et d'assurer la
transparence dans les financements
jacqueline eustache brinio est ce que
vous diriez qu'aujourd'hui le
financement des cultes le manque de
transparence dans son ensemble est-ce
que c'est valable pour tous les cultes
ou c'est avant tout valable pour l'islam
puisque ce texte a aussi pour objectif
de lutter contre l'islamisme radical
je crois qu'aujourd'hui il faut pas se
tromper en a un objectif c'est de mieux
connaître le financement du culte
musulman ni larmes ans sellal l'objectif
de la loi je voudrais juste dire deux
mots avant l'objectif de cette loi qui
est un titre que pas dire grand chose ça
chacun peut avoir son idée
les prochains mois qui conforte le voilà
on fait des principes sains quand même
de lutter contre le séparatisme qui est
une réalité dans ce pays d'accord par
différentes par différents biais moi je
trouve sa loi très technique très très
technique le sénat il a apporté un
certain nombre d'éléments la semaine
dernière on verra ce que ça devient mais
voilà et dans dans les aspects très
techniques très législatives il y a
effectivement la transparence du
financement du financement des cultes de
manière globale mais quel est celui qui
aujourd'hui est le moins transparent
c'est celui là clairement donc oui c'est
un des objectifs
après bien évidemment une nouvelle
s'applique à tous donc elle va
s'appliquer à tout le monde aujourd'hui
est d'ailleurs lorsque nous y avons
travaillé il ya un an au sénat dans le
cas de la commission denquête ça et
c'était l'une des premières
préconisations
regardez surveiller ces financements
étrangers qui viennent de partout qui
permettent à certains ennemis de la
république de fonctionner sur notre
propre territoire
c'est juste plus possible donc
aujourd'hui cet aspect là était écrit
cet aspect là et il a défini et il
permettra finalement de regarder les
choses différemment je voudrais juste
revenir sur une chose après je vais
évidemment j'ai pas un mot ne plus être
que la parole l'ingérence des pays
étrangers et juste insupportable dans
notre pays
en tout cas c'est quelque chose que nous
devons combattre tous les cas sur ans où
on parle de l'âge et la mauritanie qui
la turquie le maroc nous nions pas aussi
enfin voilà donc aujourd'hui il faut que
les choses soient très claires et je
pense que le fait qu'on puisse
effectivement aujourd'hui regardez ce
qui se passe
s'opposer à des financements ça me
paraît très important
est ce que c'est un effet plutôt
consensuel dans ce texte qui par
ailleurs ne l'est pas esther benbassa
plus de transparence dans le culte avant
tout que on voit qu'il ya certaines
structures musulmanes qui pourrait sous
couvert d'activités culturelles comme
l'aide aux devoirs par exemple diffuser
une forme d'islam radical et aux
prosélytes et à travers et bien le fait
de remonter dans les financements on
espère pouvoir lutter contre ce type de
phénomène auquel nous sommes tous ici
tout convaincu qu'il faut combattre le
terrorisme il faut combattre l'islamisme
salafistes l'islamisme politique mais ce
texte qui a n'est ce pas été élaboré
après l'assassinât de samuel pâtit
m
un texte très restrictif un tiers des
articles visent à un enfant contient des
dispositifs pour combattre le terrorisme
mais ce sont surtout des dispositifs qui
est vont contrôler l'islam l'islam de
tout le monde parce qu'il n'ya pas
l'islamisme seulement de contrôler et
encore définis dans le cadre d'un carnet
rémi donelle d'emprisonnement il ya il
faut remonter un petit peu très
rapidement toutes les religions
monothéistes ont été soumises au
concordat est l'islam pas puisque il n'y
avait pas de sentiment
lors du concordat bon aujourd'hui c'est
vrai que l'islam reste un peu disons en
sans avoir des règlements
comme il n'ya pas de hiérarchie dans
l'islam qu'il n'y a pas une tête il ya
la chique et lui définit désigné mais le
problème n'est pas là je crois
qu'aujourd'hui il ya deux choses
combattre le terrorisme
combattre l'islamisme est organisée
l'islam
voilà il faut sélectionner moi je
voudrais finir si on n'organise pas
l'islam d'europe et qu on ne forme pas
des imams on aura de l'argent de
l'étranger puisque c'est une communauté
très pauvre encore avec une petite
classe moyenne
il n'y a pas ces d'imams c'est les turcs
et les marocains qui vont envoyer des
images
culte donc tout cela fait que ce texte
me paraît vraiment une sorte de mise
sous tutelle de l'islam comme le dit
d'ailleurs l'archevêque de reims qui m'a
écrit comme le dit le représentant des
des protestants on est revenus sur la
loi de 1905
je rends va demander à l'imam chalghoumi
ce qu'il en pense et ce que vous vous
ressentez ce texte aujourd'hui comme une
mise sous tutelle de l'islam pour
reprendre les propos d'esther benbassa
et comment il ya que pensez-vous et de
cette mesure contenue dans le texte qui
vise à assurer plus de transparence
financière dans votre culte bonjour à
tout le monde je pense qu' il fallait
entre l'islam et l'islamisme ça c'est la
première chose que telvent dix personnes
des musulmans de france de l'europe
ils pratiquent un islam apaisé et
respectent les lois de leur payer et
qu'ils veulent vivre en harmonie et la
stabilité de leur vie et leurs enfants
mais malheureusement on peut pas avoir
un islam éclairé un islam de france que
je le nomme et j'espère qu'un islam
européen tant qu'on lutte pas contre 2
l'islamisme et l'islam la gérance
étrangères la loi pour moi cette loi il
n'y pas contre les musulmans
elle est contre l'islamisme le 90 par
sont des musulmans sont pas touchés par
cette loi c'est qui
si qu'ils ont plus de crainte ce sont
les islamistes se sont qu'ils ont
l'argent qui vient de l'étranger comme
le milieu uche comme les organisations
qui refuse de signer le pacte est reçu
dans leur fils de signer la charte que
cette charte ont pour moi les valeurs
que mes temps en honneur la femme
musulmane en même temps aussi vous savez
c'est une avancée historique
on est aujourd'hui c'est 1905 musulmans
la république son devoir de protéger les
musulmans contre l'islamisme contre les
sectes contre les désirs des rives par
deux moyens par les finances et par le
thé contre l'idéologie et bien justement
vous venez de parler de meego ruche
c'est parce qu'il ya aussi une actualité
qui est venu percuter à l'examen de ce
projet de loi au parlement c'est la
sphère de la mosquée de strasbourg
dharmanand le ministre de l'intérieur
accuse en effet la municipalité
écologiste je le cite de financer une
ingérence étrangère sur le sol français
en accordant une subvention dans le
cadre de ce projet notez d'ailleurs que
la préfète a saisi hier la justice pour
annuler cette subvention de 2 5 millions
d'euros on va en parler en plateau on va
aller voir tout d'abord la réaction de l
achat local et au micro d'alexandre
poussard les sénatrices les républicains
du bas rhin tout cela se passe sur son
territoire effectivement elle a salque
qui est conseillère municipale
d'opposition à la mairie de strasbourg
et l achat qu'est ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec gérald darmanin qui estime
que la majorité écologistes à strasbourg
finances l'ingérence turc sur le sol
français avec ce projet de mosquée je
pense qu'avec cette délibération la
maire de strasbourg a commis une faute
et en tant que strasbourgeoise en tant
que co mossé hier municipal d'opposition
nous avons voté évidemment contre cette
délibération pendant le conseil
municipal avec mes collègues du groupe
heller à la ville c'est une faute de
l'exécutif en fait strasbourgeois
d'avoir accordé cette subvention alors
qu'effectivement l'organisation
islamique qu'ils l'apportent a refusé de
signer en fait la charte sur les
principes républicains
alors le gouvernement le ministère de
l'intérieur on est bien alerté la
majorité écologistes à strasbourg sur
les suspicions autour de ce projet de
mosquée autour de cette association sur
le sous influence turque comment vous
expliquez que la majorité écologistes de
strasbourg persiste un peu finalement
dans ce bras de fer avec le gouvernement
ça a été tout l'objet en fait du débat
d'ailleurs en conseil municipal en fait
de strasbourg des points en fait
dallaire des points en fait d'opposition
parce que justement il fallait obtenir
en fait des garanties de la part de
cette organisation
la majorité municipale a décidé en fait
finalement de passer de passer cette
délibération c'est sa responsabilité
mais effectivement non seulement on s'y
est opposé mais on estime qu' il faut
d'une part un plan de financement qui
est clair qui n'est pas obscurs comme
c'est le cas jusque jusqu'à présent il
faut qu'il y ait des garanties certaines
et pire la maire de strasbourg a créé un
précédent en accordant en fait une
subvention alors que la promo pose de la
première pierre avait avait été déjà
fait en fait par le passé et c'était un
engagement qui avait été pris de la part
d'anciens maires de ne pas
de ne pas financer alors que la pose de
la première pierre se fait justement la
première pierre de cette mosquée a été
posée avant l'arrivée des écologistes à
strasbourg les élus dans les mandatures
précédentes étaient plutôt d'accord avec
ce projet pourquoi ça pose problème
maintenant est ce qu'il n'ya pas aussi
une instrumentalisation politique de la
part du gouvernement
dans le débat actuel sur sur l'islamisme
je crois qu'il ya une vraie difficulté
en fait de temporalité de cette
délibération aussi et je ne comprends
pas et je m'interroge aussi à titre
personnel pourquoi la maire de
strasbourg a tenu à passer cette
délibération
de 2,5 millions à cette organisation
islamique pour la construction de ce
lieu de culte
maintenant on est en plein débat sur
justement le projet de loi sur les
principes républicains
ici au sénat et on voit bien à quel
point c'était essentiel d'avoir
justement les garanties d'avoir en fait
les principes républicains réaffirmé et
ça pose bien évidemment questionnements
quant au choix en fait de l'exécutif
municipal
alors on le précise il y aura une
seconde délibération sur cette
subvention accordée pour la construction
de cette mosquée est ce que les
écologistes peuvent faire machine
arrière selon vous j'espère nous
d'ailleurs au niveau de strasbourg avec
les collègues du groupe
lr nous avons demandé le retrait pur et
simple de cette délibération
nous avons vu que la préfète déférer la
délibération devant la justice et nous
avons appris tout à l'heure par un
communiqué de la ville de strasbourg que
la ville et la municipalité allait
plaider pour la légalité de cette
délibération et je regrette que la maire
de strasbourg persiste dans ce que je
considère être une véritable foot
merci beaucoup à celle que d'avoir
répondu à mes questions et donc vous le
voyez ta main la majorité collagiste à
strasbourg persiste dans ce bras de fer
avec le gouvernement autour de cette
mosquée merci beaucoup alexandre prisca
thévenot justement pour eux élevés c'est
une je le cite cabale médiatique
orchestrée par le parti de la majorité
il parle d'une polémique politicienne
sur un projet vieux d'une 10
zen d'année qu'est ce que vous répondez
fresca thévenot non jours il s'agit pas
d'une polémique ont ils on n'est pas
dans une démarche de polémique
au contraire il s'agit d'en finir avec
ces petites phrases et ses coups
médiatiques qui sont pour moi des coûts
purement de curseur est de se placer sur
l'échiquier politique je pense qu'on a
besoin d'autre chose surtout dans le
contact dans le contexte que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui que un contexte
de crise sanitaire déjà pour rappel
effectivement il n'a pas été stoppé le
projet de la mosquée à strasbourg c'est
le ministre gérald darmanin qui a
demandé à la préfète de déférer la
délibération on parle de 2 5 millions
d'euros demandés en subventions pour
financer une associée une mosquée via
l'association une association qui refuse
de donner un plan de financement en
toute transparence et qui refusent de
signer une charte républicaine donc déjà
là se pose un premier problème
ensuite il faut pas oublier qu'une
subvention c'est un acte politique
et on peut aussi se poser la question
que dans un climat tel que nous le
vivons aujourd'hui 2,5 millions d'euros
pourrait aussi encore une fois là il
s'agit pas de faire d'ingérence mais de
poser un débat serein et éclairé de 5
millions d'euros à titre d'exemple c200
création de places de crèche c'est
plusieurs années de financement
d'associations qui luttent contre les
violences faites aux femmes
donc je vais dire que je pense encore
une fois qu'il ne s'agit pas d'en faire
un débat de rapport de force mais plutôt
de pouvoir poser clairement clairement
et sereinement
cela est de pouvoir le faire sans être
taxé de faire quelques actions contre
quelques mouvements politiques que ce
soit esther benbassa casque
qu'est ce que vous répondez il trouve
que meego russe et dont parlait hassen
chalghoumi à l'instant est une
organisation que si réputée proche
d'ankara qu'effectivement a refusé de
signer la fameuse charte en ce début
d'année est ce que ce n'est pas un
problème pour accorder une subvention de
deux millions et demi d'euros
d'abord tu il faut dire que nous sommes
en alsace lorraine et en alsace moselle
sous la coupe du concordat laitages
aide les associations aident les cultes
et le culte musulman c'est celui qui
comparativement jeu soit le moins de
fonds on n'est pas en métropole on est
là il faut aimer se faire un réseau
d'accords deuxièmement et milli gorus
c'est une c'est une association bon
cette association a été subventionné par
l'état la dernière subvention date de
2020 il ya eu une subvention donnée à
cette association part de l'état et aux
paramore auparavant il y avait une
subvention de la préfecture donc c'est
pas nouveau et le plus le prédécesseur
de madame balle séguin avait aidé cette
association
ce monsieur sarr qu'il qui décide qui
est dirigée milli gorus a été reçu chez
le président de la république il ya même
une photo qui l'attestent
et ensuite il faut ajouter que c'est à
la préfecture et 2e au ministère de
l'intérieur
d'avertir la municipalité de 2,2 de
l'évolution de ceux de cette association
et je voudrais ajouter corriger quelque
chose
le l'état avait déjà donné de l'argent
pour la mosquée et cette mosquée elle
n'est pas encore finie n'est pas encore
construite entièrement et il faut finir
en disant quand même que la la
subvention n'a pas été donné et qu'il y
à une seconde étape que l'aah il a été
autorisé mais n'est pas versé les choses
quand même au point et ensuite je ne
sais pas il faut dire quand même que ce
monsieur est le secrétaire général
du cfcm n'est ce pas un culte musulman
oui alors de l'extérieur cette personne
ne représente rien de répréhensible
voilà enfin il faut mettre les choses au
point et nomma vert de la polémique
seulement en disant voilà c'est les
écologistes parce qu'il ya un écolo
bashing c'est ainsi qu'ils aient fait
part de la reine en citant ce truc de
jal darmanin qui dit la mairie verte de
strasbourg finance une mosquée soutenu
par une fédération qui a refusé de
signer la charte des principes de
l'islam de france et qui défend un islam
politique et il ajoute vivement que tout
le monde ouvre les yeux et que la loi
séparatisme soit bientôt votée et
promulguée comment est ce que vous
faites si vous vous situez jacqueline
eustache brinio est ce que la loi
séparatisme va pouvoir empêcher ce film
se situe en tout cas la loi séparatisme
elle a effectivement écrit là elle va
donner à l'état des clés pour éviter ce
genre de choses moi je voudrais revenir
quand même sur cette subvention ce que
les écologistes sont très forts pour
défendre les ennemis de la république
clairement ce que le milieu riche tout
le monde sait comment il fonctionne
tout le monde sait exactement d'où
viennent les influences de 1000 go russe
puisque c'est quand même ils sont à la
botte du président de la turquie
actuelle erdogan est derrière tout ça
donc on est quand même bon voilà je suis
pas sûr que ce soit le grand ami de la
france monsieur erdogan
mais au-delà de ça on a aujourd'hui dans
nos villes et strasbourg est l'exemple
concret y à grenoble c'est vrai il ya
quand même une centaine une ville qu'ils
sont tenus par les écologistes ou je
regrette franchement c'est l'absence de
réalisme voilà être dans le déni de ce
qui se passe dans notre pays c'est juste
pour moi il responsable on peut avoir
des idées politiques différentes
on a un ennemi commun c'est l'islamisme
c'est clair --nous effectivement ne
mélangeons pas tout nous nous battons
pas contre les musulmans
nous nous battons contre des musulmans
les ennemis de la république et ça si
tout le monde en a pas conscience
franchement ca c g donc vous conviendrez
que le roi dans le cadre de la mosquée
de strasbourg c
grand bien leur écoute et en plein en
plein ce sujet d'accord en pleine loi
d'abord cette loi elle fait pas réponse
à l'assassinât monstrueux ça mais elle
pâtit ça fait quand même l est de l
année 2015 avoir 2012 que la france
subit des attentats terroristes
islamistes
rappelons le donc moi je dirais que ça
des lois les mêmes par div
et d'ailleurs cette loi va pas tout
régler parce que c'est comme je lé dit
la semaine dernière au sénat c'est la
petite pierre d'un rempart qu'on a
construit pour se protéger donc voilà
donc même voilà ma collègue elle
comparait elle disait récemment que nono
nous chassions les musulmans comme les
juifs ont été chassés dans notre pays
mais c'est juste franchement
insupportable air en vichy maladie de
leur dynamisme elle dit nos amis sont à
l'aris la mise donc les islamistes nous
devons les combattre et je finis ça
parce que c'est très important
on peut pas comparer quand même voilà il
ya des choses passent de l'histoire
qu'on peut pas comparer aujourd'hui on a
un ennemi qui est chez nous et nous
devons tous le combat et le clientélisme
des verts aujourd'hui est dangereux et
dangereux parce que non seulement il
enferme une partie la communauté
musulmane dans des dogmes et dans des
des principes qui font sortir des
enfants de la république qui vont sortir
une partie de la jeunesse de la
république et ça je trouve ça très très
grave donc voilà aujourd'hui le millet
go russe était un ennemi de la france
eh bien nous devons pas donner d'argent
allait me la france et moi je suis
d'accord avec monsieur darmanin quand il
dit il ya des choses qui ne seront plus
possibles
et tant mieux et tant mieux je vous
laisserai pas dire que je ne vais pas
défendre billig lui je suis pas l'amour
ça je n'ai aucun intérêt vous parlez de
clientélisme la droite fait du client
mais il y en a sur le dos vers son
champion
de la population c'est pas les bêtes
vient d'arriver ils n'ont pas à faire du
clientélisme et vous arrêter quand même
de déformer ce que j'ai dit pour vous ce
qui est arrivé aux juifs c'est que vichy
enfin il ya eu tout le xixème siècle il
y à une affaire dreyfus et c'est alors
vous pour vous la ville ce qui est
arrivé au jeu se résume à vichy même si
c'était là la partie l'annoncé de rage
il sait écouter ce texte ce texte
stigmatise pas de les musulmans des deux
milieux mais même si je suis entièrement
d'accord qu'il faut combattre l'islam il
va john est le terrorisme nous allons
écouter les évêques de race écoutez le
responsable du protestantisme allègement
forêt d un grave et non vous savez bien
que ça touche tous les cultes y adhérer
telle question surtout là-bas c'est
logique ça danse et apprenez à lir pas
stigmatisation elle évalue loi ne
s'appliquait aux rebelles
présentation allez on va essayer
d'avancer un petit peu nous couper dans
ce cas la peine de nous poser des
questions enfin c'est d'avancer aussi
dans le débat ça les autres personnes
qui participent à ce débat hassen
chalghoumi on va essayer de parler aussi
un petit peu de cette question qu'on
avait évoqué dans le début de l'émission
celle des imams détaché le contrôle de
la formation des imams
est ce que ce n'est pas là la lune des
difficultés aussi face à l'islamisme
ou est-ce qu'on en ait dans ce chantier
qui pour le coup ne figure pas au sens
de la loi et moratti sme cet homme a
acheté voilà moi je trouve que oui et
tout à fait tout à fait j'ai dit à mon
signé ça que j'ai déjà parlé aussi haut
responsable au ministère de l'intérieur
et les personnes qui sont concernées par
le sujet c'est le sujet de la formation
des imams c'est la clé aussi il faut
qu'on a un moment de trouver les moyens
pour former nos imams en france taupe et
saisit même qui vient de l'étranger
parce que dès qu on a une référence
biologique en france en un dixième
français qui sont en france
st je trouve un des solutions de stopper
cette ingérence comme il le faut le
milieu riche mais je voulais juste une
petite remarque tout à l'heure vous
savez c'est pas la loi que les stingers
stigmatise les musulmans
les islamistes ne stigmatise les
assassins les tuyères sur qui salit
destin musulmans aussi malheureusement
j'ai quand même un parent de ma
responsabilité
pas en tant que seulement religieux
autant que citoyen j ai honte de
certains responsables politiques qui
s'associer avec des personnes qui salit
l'islam les musulmans et aussi qui prend
l'islam et les musulmans et surtout la
cause palestinienne comme un fonds de
commerce pour attirer parce que les
milieux riches ce sont le bras droit le
bras aussi politique même presque armée
de erdogan et qui on a eu une période de
menaces contre la france compterait des
personnes non visibles contre notre
président je pense que le minimum
responsable multiples d'avoir cette
responsabilité ne pas s'associer avec
des organisations et des mauves ans
comme celle de méluche prisca thévenot
le problème aussi pour la formation des
imams c'est que il faut pouvoir et bien
organisez faut pouvoir la finance
emmanuel macron annonce la fin des imams
détaché en 2024 à ce que tout cela c'est
réaliste
il va falloir aussi trouver le
financement pour l'islam de france
il s'agit effectivement d'accompagner
cela de décider de manière arbitraire et
extrêmement rapide une de prendre une
telle décision n'aurait pas de sens ça
ne serait effectivement qu'une loi pour
une loi donc il s'agit d'accompagner
cela est de le faire en bonne
intelligence avec l'ensemble des acteurs
en présence
effectivement je vais rajouter par
rapport à ce qu'a dit monsieur
chalghoumi c'est que attention je pense
que le texte est très clair c'est un
texte équilibré qui nomme les choses et
qui surtout n'a aucune aucune vocation à
diviser parce que rappelant que ces de
ses divisions que se nourrissent et qui
est le terreau de ceux justement qui
s'en prennent à la république donc je
pense que nous avons tous une
responsabilité
effectivement religieuse pour les imams
politique pour madame les sites les
sénatrices citoyenne pour ma part de
faire attention que aucune récupération
quelle qu'elle soit qui viennent semer
le doute sur l'ambition est l'objectif
de ce texte ne puisse être rattrapé et
finalement utilisé contre nous il s'agit
vraiment de défendre la république est
absolument pas faire de fer d'algal d'
amalgame pardon entre les musulmans et
l'islam isme il ya bien deux choses
différentes
je voudrais jouer esther benbassa ont
écrit sur la question aussi de du
financement de l'islam qui est vraiment
l'un des points d'interrogation comment
est ce qu'on va pouvoir mieux financer
une religion récente qui n'a pas
forcément les mêmes installations les
mêmes écoles et même
la situation économique nécessaire pour
pouvoir être etc
moi je dis d'abord que jusque là la
laïcité et notre vraiment socle commun
et cette laïcité est basée sur le
respect la liberté du culte là il ya un
vrai problème avec ce texte
au niveau de la réécriture d'une loi qui
affluent qui a été notre fonds communs
et que l'équipe sera maintenant disons
on travaille bien sur la liberté des
culs de cette partie de la loi de 1905
ensuite je me dis le problème le plus
important aujourd'hui ça aurait été de
former des imams ça aurait été de
trouver des solutions pour ne pas
laisser l'islam se servent ils de
l'argent qui vient de l'étranger
si vous n'avez pas d'argent d'accord et
c'est une communauté pauvre qui ne peut
pas payer ces imams d'ailleurs c'est un
problème à tous les niveaux
essayons de ne pas faire le lit de
l'islamisme n'est ce pas essayons de
combattre les discriminations essayons
d'aller là où l'islamisme pouces essayé
d'envoyer des imams couvert fort mais
aussi à la théologie cas qu science
moderne de l'islam des religions écoutez
ce n'est pas en un jour qu'on va faire
moi je ne suis pas l'état voilà je vais
quand même les solutions à chercher ce
n'est pas seulement en tapant sur les
sur les musulmans d'ailleurs du
défenseur de l'as défenseur des droits
jusqu'aux scènes cdh tout le monde
considère que ce texte est liberticide
stigmatisant et je vous cite les
supposés des motifs de ce texte pour
faire joli
l'entrisme communautarisme
communautariste insidieux mais puissant
gang rhin lentement les fondements de
notre société
dans certains territoires cet entrisme
et pour l'as l'essentiel d'inspiration
islamiste quand vous lisez cela va dans
les forêts des motifs vraiment vous êtes
mal votre réponse à jacqueline eustache
brinio alex ouemba c'est juste la
réalité ce qui se passe dans le pays
ça fait 20 ans qu'on lutte contre
l'islamisme qui ça
si misant notre pays qui fait en sorte
qu'aujourd'hui des petites filles ne
vont plus à l'école et petites filles
sont voilées dans les banlieues donc
arrêtons de dollars on ne stigmatise pas
un fait pas d'un amalgame
on dit qu'il ya une partie de la société
qui sort de la société c'est pas notre
conception de notre concession c'est
dans un pays pas fracturée et au nom de
l'islam isme aujourd'hui ça paye se
fracturent donc arrêtons d'être dans le
déni en permanence parce qu'on n'avance
pas donc pour en plus enfin le seul à
dire c'est que nous faisons ça aussi
pour ces musulmans d'abord qui subissent
qu'ils subissent dans les quartiers
cette pression cette mainmise des
religieux les plus orthodoxes les plus
terribles qui vont en sorte que des gens
les peut-être les plus plus faibles les
plus en difficulté rabelais les plus
vulnérables par delà lui donc voilà
c'est notre responsabilité est il cette
france elle est une et indivisible et
laïque
d'accord la religion ça doit rester dans
la sphère privée on ne l'imposent pas un
autre et on impose passé d'homme à une
collectivité qui n'en veut pas et ce
texte ne répond pas pour moi
complètement mais il répond en tout cas
sur un certain nombre de clés dont on a
besoin pour y faire face le chantier va
durer des années
faut pas croire que nous allons remettre
en cause ce que nous subissons de vingt
20 ans en mettant tout sur la table en
disant que tout va bien
n'oublions pas les 300 morts n'oublions
pas les attentats et n'oublions pas les
familles qui ont ils laissé quelqu'un de
leur famille mais qui en vivent
aujourd'hui des douleurs et des
conséquences très graves
c'est ça et la france est en europe le
pays les plus menacés et nous devons
trouver les clés mais pour y faire face
merci merci à tous les cadres d'avoir
participé à ce débat un débat enflammé
qui vous donne un avant goût et là des
discussions qu'il va y avoir encore dans
l'hémicycle
cette semaine nous sommes maintenant à
30 minutes du débat du début des
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
tous nos journalistes sont en place
alexandre plus arts salle des
conférences
jean mathia sur twitch estime jourdain
dans l'hémicycle on va passer un petit
peu en revue de façon plus détaillée les
thèmes abordés cet après midi avec vous
et steve wheaton qu'est ce qui a été
fait depuis un an pour faciliter l'école
à domicile voilà l'une des questions qui
sera posée cet après midi au
gouvernement rappel des faits depuis
hier les établissements scolaires sont
fermés en france l'école à distance
l'enseignement à distance et généraliser
l'enseignement à distance et à la norme
le problème est bien c'est que cette
première journée d'enseignement ne s'est
pas vraiment passé comme prévu de
nombreux bugs informatiques ont perturbé
les cours hier et continue d'ailleurs de
les perturber aujourd'hui pourtant
pourtant jean-michel bancaire avait
promis que tout serait prêt pour une
nouvelle session d'école à domicile
qu'est ce qui s'est passé qu'est ce qui
ne fonctionne pas c'est ce que les
sénateurs vont essayer de savoir cet
après-midi autre sujet autre thème
abordé cet après-midi dans l'hémicycle à
l'avenir du secteur aérien on appris
lundi que le groupe a forcé les bien
être recapitalisées par l'état ça c'est
à la suite du feu vert donné par
bruxelles au plan proposé par le
gouvernement français
rqap italie recapitalisation contre
cession à des concurrents de créneaux
horaires quotidiens décalage
atterrissage à l'aéroport d'orly le
problème est bien c'est que cette
session inquiète les syndicats les
syndicats s'inquiètent craignent que ces
créneaux soient cédés à des concurrents
locaux c'est donc que l'avenir de
milliers d'emplois soit menacée à moyen
long terme
c'est ce que le gouvernement devra le
gouvernement devra essayer bien de
rassurer un peu tout le monde cet après
midi dans l'hémicycle ta main merci
beaucoup steam on vous retrouve dans
moins d'une demi heure maintenant et on
va parler bien d'un des sujets qui va
être abordée dans l'hémicycle cet
après-midi les débuts un petit peu
chaotique hier de l'école à la maison
les profs les élèves sont apparus plutôt
bien rondes rodez après
le premier confinement mais les outils
numériques ont eux connu un gros
plantage a provoqué l'exaspération de
beaucoup de personnes
les enseignants les parents les enfants
alors l'école est elle prête pour le 3e
confinement c'est l'objet de notre face
à face avec david dacko belli bonjour
bon sénateur r&d pays des hauts-de-seine
est un des pays le groupe de la majorité
présidentielle ici au sénat et jacques
grosperrin bonjour bonjour ce matin les
républicains du doubs d'abord et on va
faire un petit retour sur la journée
compliquée d'hier pour les élèves à la
maison avec jordan comme des messages
d'erreur voilà ce qui s'affichait hier
lors des connexions à la plate forme de
cours en ligne premiers jours de
distance yale et première difficulté des
bugs à répétition signalés par des
élèves des parents ou des professeurs
cacophonie l'absence d'informations le
flou aussi le manque de cadres h un
petit peu le un petit peu le le bazar
finalement yale par exemple des des
messages d'erreur qui sont apparus dès
des sites qui étaient bloqués ou encore
des des classes virtuelles inaccessible
une situation qui aurait été provoquée
par des piratages
le ministre de l'éducation nationale
dénonce alors hier des attaques
informatiques
apparemment venus de l'étranger pour
empêcher les serveurs de fonctionner
depuis une enquête a été ouverte à paris
pour tenter de trouver les responsables
lors de son intervention dans une classe
de collège en visioconférence
le président de la république a même
brièvement évoqué le problème
ce matin il ya eu quelques difficultés
est ce que vous avez vu sur le plan
technique qu'au niveau national il ya eu
apparemment des incidents et peut-être
des malveillances en tout cas je pense
que c'est
c'est important de de continuer de
perdre le moins de temps scolaire
possible durant cette période
une situation qui n'a pas semblé touché
toutes les régions de manière égale
c'est ce qu'a laissé entendre le
président de la région provence alpes
côte d'azur
je constate que ça va marcher que chez
nous ça a marché c'est à dire que la com
et anticipée de façon plus importante
mais on l'a fait en fait avant le coc
vis de nous donc on n'était pas dans
l'urgence nous on avait fait un choix
stratégique dans le cadre de l'éducation
avec le recteur avec les conseils
pédagogiques des différents lycées pour
informatiser et sortir du papier et à
entrer dans la tablette l'école à la
maison avait aussi mal commencé l'année
dernière lors du premier confinement le
gouvernement assuré depuis que tout
était prêt en cas de nouvel épisode de
distance yale face à ces nouveaux
quoique certains professeurs pointe du
doigt de l'impréparation de la part des
autorités à l'aria tulle
y at il eu un préparation en tout cas un
rapport de novembre dernier commandité
par l'éducation nationale parlait déjà
de la fragilité des ent environnement
numérique de travail lors de la crise
sanitaire de 2020 des ent qui ont été
énormément mis à contribution regardez
il ya eu lors du premier confinement 550
millions de visites et 12 millions de
visiteurs 226 % d'augmentation du trafic
est déjà de nombreux problèmes de
connexion xavier iacovelli on n'a pas su
tirer les enseignements et bien de cette
première vague de la crise sanitaire
déjà je pense qu'il faut faire le
distinguo entre le cned qui
effectivement sous la tutelle du
ministère de l'éducation nationale et où
là effectivement il y a eu informatique
qui a été dénoncée par le ministre de
l'éducation nationale et avec des
mesures très rapides qui ont été mis en
place pour corriger ces attaques et
faire en sorte que les plateformes
refonctionne et puis parallèlement il ya
les ent qui elles dépendent à 100% des
régions et on voit bien et comme le dit
le président muselier on voit bien que
d'une région à l'autre on n'a pas eu les
mêmes problèmes et 30 discrètement j'ai
vu au niveau de l'île de france
on a vu effectivement que l'île de
france a été particulièrement touchée
sur les ent notamment aussi parce qu'on
est passé de 90 mille enfants ados à 400
mhz il ya un matin mais aussi parce qu
on a creusé un petit peu notamment avec
laurent saint martin notre candidat pour
l'élection régionale on a creusé un peu
les chiffres et on a regardé la région
ile-de-france a dotés de moins de 10%
les ent cette année et donc c'est vrai
que contrairement peut-être un monsieur
muselier qui lui apparemment a investi
et à anticiper et bats la région
ile-de-france menée par madame pécresse
a sous dotées les ent qui provoque
aujourd'hui certainement ce bug
c'est une erreur des régions nous dit
xavier iacovelli au passage en
ile-de-france avec un petit tacle à
valérie pécresse à jacques grosperrin
oui on voit bien qu'on est déjà dans le
cadre des régionales parce que je crois
que si c'était cela ça serait pas très
compliqué moi j'ai l'impression que le
prison le prix dans la république a
souhaité fermer les écoles que le
ministre de l'éducation nationale ne le
souhaitait pas qu'il était pris de court
moi je veux bien croire qu'ils aient des
difficultés mais suite c'est comme le
troisième confinement donc on se trouve
dans une situation difficile difficile
pour les enfants pour les parents pour
les chefs d'établissement il faut pas
les oublier parce que c'est sont eux qui
sont en première ligne avec les parents
donc si toutes ces difficultés montre
comment donner il a peut-être aussi une
une impréparation encore vous savez
lorsque vous discutez on n'a pas senti
tellement d'impréparation du côté des
enseignants même jamais enfants
maintenant ça vraiment comment utiliser
vraiment ça a été une numérique qui a
joint c'est l'impression jamais sans moi
je vais pas faire la politique de la
politique politicienne vous savez
bon certains indices vont le cnes a bien
fonctionné s'est rétabli les autres ça
fonctionne moins bien et c'est je crois
que surtout les difficultés et et tous
les hauts fonctionnaires ou le disent
c'est qu'ils aient un système
informatique de l'éducation nationale
qui ne fonctionne pas bien
je pense qu'il faudra absolument
dé-bor-dée ce système là parce qu'on se
rend compte que il appliquait pas
suffisamment de personnes qui
travaillent au sein de cet établissement
qu'on appelle les ministères du
classement national et on s'y retrouve
chaque fois quand même chaque fois à des
situations où les enfants sont pas en
capacité de pouvoir se brancher sur les
émeutes et je parle pas de ce que vous
avez dit tout à l'heure c'est à dire au
monde au nez on peut très bien avoir
déterminé les lieux on peut avoir
beaucoup de choses par rapport à cela
mais un système français qui est très
pyramidale avec l'éducation nationale
qui est en charge
c'est elle qui a décidé de confiner et
de faire en sorte que de fermer l'école
c'est le 14e le de le faire donc c'était
c'est à elle d'abord cette
responsabilité là pour que ça fonctionne
bien au niveau local au niveau
territorial à céret mulhouse avait
raison c'est à ça que vous avez raison
c'est une décision qui a été une
décision nationale sur le confinement
est en tout cas sur le fait de faire
l'école pendant quatre jours en distance
yale et avec une anticipation des
vacances scolaires ça c'est une décision
nationale
après effectivement la décision aussi de
maintenir ses cours à distance c'est une
décision nationale mais après les
plateformes numériques
et c'est pas à vous chers collègues que
qui est attachée à la décentralisation
et au fait que les régions puissent
avoir un et les territoires puissent
avoir des responsabilités
aujourd'hui la gestion le financement et
la tutelle unique des ent c'est les
régions mais qui ce n'est pas l'état qui
pilote qui pilote c'est les résultats
pilotes à travers avec ses les régions
avec les rita katz et les régions et
loch ness je suis complètement d'accord
avec vous le cned c'est sous tutelle du
ministère mais aujourd'hui les ent qui
ont planté et qui ont fait un maximum de
bugs
hier c'est les régions et encore une
fois on voit bien qu'il ya des
disparités d'une région à nantes ce qui
prouve bien qu'on n'a pas les mêmes
outils et on n'a pas peut-être une
harmonisation et les mêmes nécessités
jour d'une région vous êtes forcé pas
sur la responsabilité
il ya eu plus de l'entendre non mais je
peux l'entendre il ya eu un bug c'est
compliqué où absolument que les écoles
continuent à fonctionner et je trouve
que c'est bien maintenant il y a des
difficultés on le sait au sein du
ministère d'éducation nationale ya
vraiment qu il ya une vraie faiblesse au
niveau du numérique on le sait tout le
monde le dit depuis des années donc ça
veut dire qu'il ya on doit en prendre
les enseignements on doit réfléchir à ça
et puis peut-être qu'on doit faire appel
à des sociétés extérieures pourquoi ça
fonctionne bien dans les autres pays
pourquoi on n'a pas ce souci là mais
sakho la cdc des prestataires extérieurs
aujourd'hui ceux qui gèrent la forme
prestataires extérieurs
ils sont sous tutelle des régions mais
ses détracteurs et donc c'est pour ça
que moi je demande aujourd'hui est ce
qu'il y a un plan de continuité
numérique
est ce que le plan au niveau de
notamment de l'agression et de france a
été mis en place et c'est ça ou on peut
douter
peut-être qu'il ya des régions qui ont
mis en place ce plan de continuité et
d'autres qu'ils n'ont pas mis en place
et c'est ça la réalité c'est que quand
on a des prestataires vous savez très
bien sauf que là il faut que la poussée
il faut il faut que celle mini cela
sollicite public puisse contrôler non
non c'est vous étiez là hier même si
lyon ne vous donnez pas sur les plateaux
de jeu lorsque l'état est responsable de
quelque chose il assume ses
responsabilités lorsque l'état et le
gouvernement a faim il y a dû équiper et
faire une prime d'équipements
informatiques et les enseignants au mois
de février
il l'a fait pour l'ensemble des
enseignants donc quand la con et à ses
responsabilités il sait y faire face
on va essayer d'avancer avez vous parlé
avec la peur de l'avion je crois que la
paix dans la région les sondages
démontrent qu'elle fait un gros travail
et je pense qu'on peut pas lui reprocher
cela en tout cas les responsabilités ça
fait trois fois que s'arrête je pense
qu'on va donner on doit tirer les leçons
des sceaux ministre de les tirer
en fait il c'est à lui de tirer les
leçons d'un outil qu'il n'a pas sous
tutelle ou non mais si j'ai bien compris
c'était la défense que vous aviez
écossais y compris le président des
régions non celles des régions
ce monsieur musulin qui dit moi dans ma
région ça fonctionne bien dans les
autres ça fonctionne pas donc s'estimer
bien ce qui prouve bien que ce n'est pas
l'état mais ça la région allez on va
essayer d'avancer un petit peu parce que
en tout cas cette situation elle refera
dossier là une part de la colère des
enseignants qui estiment qu'il ya eu une
impréparation en général que ce soit les
régions que ce soit l'état
on voit des anciens qui commencent à
multiplier les great jacques grosperrin
le manque aussi de remplaçant les tests
salivaires avec reste à charge la
vaccination sur laquelle ils demandent à
être priorité à ce que vous jugez
qu'aujourd'hui les enseignants font
partie des oubliés du coc vide
bien sûr il ya beaucoup n'oubliez déco
vide je crois que c'est la pandémie est
une citation qui est singulière
ça fait plus d'un an qu'on vit avec
je pense que c'est quelque chose qui
était terriblement difficile et tout
gouvernement pour discuter on peut avoir
une attitude bienveillante vis-à-vis du
gouvernement
maintenant les choses et sont un petit
peu longue je pars faire l'histoire sur
les masques le reste les restaurateurs
sur les tests sur la vaccination etc
mais maintenant ce qu'on peut dire c'est
que on sait que le virus circule
beaucoup chez les enfants donc il faut
absolument les protéger ils ce sont des
serviteurs de l'état se sont parce que
c'est pas simplement les enseignants
c'est aussi les chefs d'établissement
soient aussi les cpe c'est aussi les
surveillants ses soucis des atsem sait
et c'est donc il faut un mois données
qui implantent du change par rapport à
ça certains s'interrogent aussi sur le
fait de vacciner les enfants parce que
si on vacciner enfants on arrivera aussi
quelque part à enrayer cette propagation
du virus donc enfin oui mais pourquoi
est il
il y avait oublié vis-à-vis des
enseignants la communauté éducative pas
parce qu'on a un vrai problème au niveau
des vaccins on le sait qu'il ya un vrai
problème parce qu'il y aura une
commission d' enquête qui sera mise en
place et on saura qui sont les
responsables
pour pouvoir non pas simplement juger
les gens c'est pas ça le but du jeu
c'est de faire en sorte que ça se
reproduise plus dans un pays qui est un
cinquième puissance mondiale
on peut pas accepter d'être en position
si lointaine dans la vaccination
xavier iacovelli est ce qu'il ya une
forme de déni sur la question des
contaminations en milieu scolaire parce
que on s'est regardé les écoles ouvertes
c'était aussi l'une des grandes fiertés
du gouvernement l'un des totems du
gouvernement et que jean michel
blanckaert pendant tout un temps n'a
cessé de se répéter qu'en tout cas ce
n'était pas à l'école qu'on se
contaminer le plus alors moi je vais pas
changer de position entre avant et après
le confinement et la fermeture des
écoles moi j'ai toujours été contre la
fermeture des écoles pour une question
de protection de l'enfance pour tout ce
qui est la question des signalements
puisque c'est le premier lieu de
signalement des violences
intrafamiliales
et puis c'est aussi une problématique
d'enseignement et d'instruction on l'a
vu pendant le premier confinement au
mois de mars en fin de mars à avril
enfin on vous met d'ailleurs on a vu 4 %
de des enfants ont été complètement
décroché on n'a pas eu de nouvelles
d'eux pendant plus de deux mois et c'est
souvent les populations les plus
fragiles dans les quartiers populaires
ceux qui sont les plus éloignés avec des
parents qui sont les plus éloignés de
l'instruction et donc on voit qu'ils ont
pas accès au numérique et qui n'ont en
plus pas accès au numérique donc c'est
la double fracture et la double sanction
donc effectivement je pense que la
france peut et quelles que soient les
clivages politiques que soit
l'appartenance politique peut être fier
d'avoir maintenu l'ouverture des écoles
après qu'ils aient eu des contaminations
à l'intérieur des écoles ça personne ne
le nie il y en a eu proportionnellement
moins que dans le reste de la population
mais il ya eu effectivement des
contaminations c'est pour ça que moi
depuis le début et même si le
gouvernement n'était pas favorable au
départ j'ai toujours dit que je
souhaitais que les la communauté
éducative et pas seulement les
enseignants mais la communauté éducative
soit prioritaire pour l'accès au vaccin
on voit bien que dans le discours du
président de l'asa n'arrive pas oui mais
ce qui est pas de gaza parce que parce
que petit à petit ça arrive mais le
président de la république a dit qu'à
partir du 15 avril effectivement un
certain nombre de publics prioritaires
devraient avoir accès notamment les
policiers les enseignants avec des
phases notamment parce que c'est pareil
on peut se poser la question est ce que
si on a un vaccin est ce que vous le
donnez un jeune enseignant de 30 ans qui
n'a pas de commandite et qui ne risque
rien ou plutôt à un enseignant retraité
de 65 ans qui lui peut effectivement
fortement si un vaccin et que donc la
réalité c'est qu'il ya aussi une
priorité
toujours des situations celle à celle du
gouvernement de vacciner en priorité
ceux qui sont les plus à risque sur sur
7 sur ce virus mais moi j'ai toujours
été favorable à la vaccination de de la
communauté éducative
elle est tout de suite on va aller voir
notre streamer politique jean jean macé
qui est sûre twitch et qui en train de
parler avec sa communauté autour de
cette séance de questions d'actualité
gens en plate on parle d'un sujet qui
doit pas mal vous intéressez intéressé
ta communauté 1 c'est celle des débuts
un petit peu difficile de l'école en
distance yale hier et puis la question
des contaminations à l'école etc etc
mais je ne le fais pas dire oui les
internautes aussi se posent des
questions sur ce qui apparaît être un
manque d'anticipation de la part de
l'éducation nationale un an après le
premier confinant un an après la mise en
place un peu car en catastrophe de
l'école à la maison à grand renfort
d'enseignants qui qui ont mouillé qui
ont mouillé la chemise café l'éducation
nationale pour anticiper ce nouveau
confinement
pourquoi y at il des bugs sur des
espaces numériques de travail
est-ce qu'il ya que des attaques
informatiques contre le cned escape a
aussi un petit manque
voilà deux préparations d'anticipation
et ça c'est vrai que si c'était le cas
bomba les internautes le pardonnerait
pas vraiment au gouvernement ça c'est un
sujet effectivement on attend de la part
d'eads et des sénateurs et des
sénatrices qu'il pose la question à jean
michel blanquer
cet après midi et surtout on attend de
sa part des réponses un autre sujet tam
qui intéresse les les internautes pour
la séance de cet après midi c'est la
mise en place de la campagne de
vaccination
l'ouverture des vaccinodromes ça y est
ça ouf ça commence à vacciner à tour de
bras
très bien mais là aussi beaucoup de
jeunes se posent des questions sur
l'anticipation de la campagne vaccinale
quand est ce qu'on va pouvoir recevoir
notre dose et comment ça va se passer
est-ce qu'on peut essayer d'avoir un
calendrier une anticipation
là encore il ya vraiment des demandes
d'anticipation et de calendrier et puis
des questions un peu plus générale sur
l'anticipation de la praye lapray
qu'ovide comment ça va se passer ce que
le gouvernement un plan pour lutter
contre les ravages du coc vide sur la
santé mentale de beaucoup de jeunes
notamment des ravages aussi sur la santé
économique la question de la reprise
économique qui inquiète beaucoup
voilà donc vraiment des demandes
d'anticipation de la part du
gouvernement de la part des internautes
pour cet après midi merci merci beaucoup
gens pour toutes ces explications
effectivement anticipation anticipation
aussi à l'école jacques grosperrin par
exemple il ya un autre sujet celui de
l'aération des locaux celui de
l'investissement dans les bâtiments il y
à antoine flahault médecin
épidémiologiste qui s'interrogeait dans
un article publié sur slate où il disait
alors que certains pays mettaient en
oeuvre des programmes de dépistage bi
hebdomadaire dans les écoles
investissait dans la vérification de la
ventilation des salles de classe et des
cantines dans les activités extérieures
des enfants qu'a donc fait le ministère
chargé de l'éducation nationale sous
l'autorité de son ministre de tutelle
jean michel blanquer pendant tout ce
temps est-ce que vous pensez que là
aussi pour le retour à l'école en
présentiel il ya quand même des choses à
préparer on peut reprocher beaucoup de
choses aux ministres on peut reprocher
beaucoup de choses au président la
république sur l'impréparation sur le
fait de ne leur a menti sur différents
points
on peut pas reprocher un mois donné le
rayonnement des écoles qui est de la
responsabilité donc l'on va pardon
arrivé à jean castex 1 le premier
ministre qui est la responsabilité bas
soit des municipalités soit des
départements soit des régions donc ça
veut dire comment donner ce qui se passe
à la terre des écoles ce qui se passe au
niveau de l'aération ce qui se passe au
niveau des investissements
là je vous rejoins c'est la compétence
des collectivités territoriales donc je
pense qu'il faut distinguer des choses
moi ce que j'aurais humide on dans cette
pandémie si singulière c'est clairement
donnée qui est pas semblant d'excusés
mais c'est qu'on nous dise véritablement
qui est une franchise puis qu'on nous
dise mais voilà nous on veut continuer
on veut faire en sorte que nos enfants
aillent à l'école et je vous rejoins et
c'est très important parce que ça
permettra à huit cent mille enfants pour
décrocher qui sortait des radars on
aurait mille qu'on nous dise voilà on a
des difficultés
on a mal géré la crise avec l'euro pour
l'as très mal géré
sur beaucoup de choses on va essayer de
faire au mieux on va essayer de les
acheter différemment
on va essayer de vacciner un peu plus de
monde mais comment ont donné qu'on ne
donne pas simplement des dates en dix
ans le 15 avril tout mon travail signer
le matin peut-être parce qu'on sait très
bien que ça sera pas le cas parce que ça
dépend pas que la france comme on n'a
pas su prendre les décisions qu'il
fallait abandonner
allez on va continuer des réactions
celle des conférences thivant parlais
tout à l'heure il va y avoir un autre
thème qui se détache cet après midi vers
beaucoup de questions autour de
l'aéronautique et notamment d'air france
est donc à votre micro alexandre le
sénateur communiste fabien gay qui va
interpeller le gouvernement sur air
france effectivement table puisque la
commission européenne a validé la
recapitalisation d'air-france par l'état
l'état qui va eh bien eh bien désormais
détenir 30% des parts de la compagnie
aérienne française
fabien gay est ce que c'est une bonne
nouvelle pour la survie d'air france
cette recapitalisation mais depuis le
début de la crise nous avons plaidé
avait le groupe communiste républicain
citoyen et écologistes pour des prises
de participations directes dans les
grandes entreprises stratégiques plutôt
que de donner des prêts garantis par
l'état sans garantie d'emploi et
d'environnement
nous nous avons porté cette idée prônons
des prises de participation mais avec
des garanties d'emploi et
environnementaux donc je suis et bruno
le maire nous a expliqué pendant des
mois
c'était impossible qu'on administré pas
l'économie qu'on n'était pas sous
l'union soviétique
un an après bon mais je vois qu'il est
convertie tant mieux mais est ce que
c'est une opération de pérenne et
quelles garanties pour l'état en termes
d'emploi 8500 suppressions d'emplois
prévues en 2 min 22 s que l'état du coup
qui est montée au capital va simplement
annuler ce plan de licenciements c'est
justement sur ce plan social qui avait
été annoncé par air france avec des
milliers de suppressions de postes est
ce que vous demandez que l'état remette
en question ce plan social le relais à
plat complètement avait bien sûr on
donne de l'argent tant mieux pour sauver
l'entreprise ça va sauver l'entreprise
ça ne veut rien dire c'est sauver les
emplois et les savoir faire
si c'est donner de l'argent public pour
payer un plan de licenciement c'est sans
nous et il faut avoir une garantie que
ces emplois se rendre pérenne et que on
amorcera aussi la nécessaire transition
écologique du du trafic aérien notamment
sur l'avion électrique et à hydrogène
donc il faut lourde
investir c'est l'état qui monte au
capital mais encore une fois pourquoi
faire et malheureusement on a
l'impression qu'en réalité
bruno le maire reste enfermé dans son
job et va ouvrir à la concurrence
notamment sur les questions des créneaux
ce qui va mettre en péril sur le long
terme l'avenir d'air france et des
salariés
et justement on le rappelle car il ya
une contrepartie à cette
recapitalisation par l'état d'air-france
c'est que air france va devoir céder et
bien 18 vols sur l'aéroport d'orly et
céder à ses concurrents ça va ça va
affaiblir la compagnie aérienne ah bah
oui vous donner 18 créneau à vos
concurrents directs et notamment la
commission européenne dit que ça
pourrait être des sur des vols low cost
donc ça va on fait bien deux fois plus
la compagnie air france est en réalité
c'est un marché de dupes donc que cas
négocier bruno le maire avec la
commission européenne et ce n'est pas
dans ce sens qu'il faut aller il faut
des garanties sur l'emploi et je
rappelle qu'il ya l'emploi direccte
chère france mais il ya aussi le point
direct il ya trente mille emplois qui
sont menacés dans la zone aéroportuaire
de roissy chez de nombreux sous titres à
air france que va faire bruno le maire
sur ces questions là il faut
conditionner les aides publiques en
termes d'emplois et environnementaux et
on écoutera à votre question au ministre
de l'économie mais surtout fabien pour
votre réaction
merci beaucoup alexandre xavier
iacovelli votre réaction à ce que les
aides de l'état doivent être
conditionnées au maintien des emplois
lorsqu'on voit les aides qui ont été
apportées à air france et les
suppressions de postes annoncées
c'est déjà ce qui alors on a changé du
tout au tout en envoyer des écoles et
moi je voulais continuer à parler des
écoles parce que je pense que c'était un
sujet majeur après sur les conditions
les conditionnement des aides publiques
moi j'ai toujours été favorable que
lorsque j'étais dans l'opposition
maintenant que dans la majorité on voit
tu avais palette je ne change pas dessus
après le fait qu' il ya une
recapitalisation d'air france par par
l'état c'est aussi pour sauver air
france et pour permettre de de sauver
cette entreprise et ce fleuron national
donc attention aussi aux contreparties
qu'ils ne puissent qui pourrait encore
plus affaiblir air france par la suite
après sur la garantie d'emploi
effectivement
il faut effectivement qu'on ait un plan
et des engagements de la direction d'air
france pour le maintien des emplois même
si effectivement il ya eu quelques uns
qui qui ont été déjà annoncées en terme
de suppressions un mot là-dessus jacques
grosperrin l'aéronautique ima ailleurs
beaucoup beaucoup de questions lors de
la séance tout à l'heure avec nautique
on le sait en très grande difficulté
avec la crise sanitaire et puis certains
pointent du doigt aussi les effets du
projet de loi climat avec a bien
l'interdiction de certaines liaisons
aériennes notamment ben là où il
pourrait y avoir un train qui pourra
faire le trajet en moins de deux heures
et demie est ce que pour vous ce sont
des inquiétudes ou bien c'est le
l'histoire en quelque sorte qui veut ça
ça va dans ce sens de l'histoire
oui dans le sens des écologistes je
crois surtout parce que qu'on se pose la
question en randonnée de l'empreinte
carbone c'est important et à droite on
ça pose aussi je pense que nous mêmes
par le moteur lorsque nous sommes à
moins de deux heures en train une fois
l'emprunt mais tout le monde ne peut pas
venir en train ça veut dire qu'il ya des
difficultés l'aviation était comme une
grande avancée de ce cycle là il faut
véritablement pas la jeter comme ça d'un
revers de main même si on arrive sur le
sur le sur le sur le climat juste les
choses par rapport aux aides d'état
sa démarche est dans une région celle
alstom et c'est également general
electric ou là est ce qu'on appelle la
production d'hydrogène
on a vu le ministre bruno lemaire venir
nous voir il faudrait qu il faut qu on
veut donner et je veux bien croire qu'il
est qu'ils soient dotés de bonnes
attention sur le fait de lier le l'aide
à ces sociétés là avec eux l'emploi qui
serait qu'il resterait sur un bassin
important mais il faut vraiment aller
jusqu'au bout parce qu'il faut pas que
sa soeur simplement des choses qui soit
un comptoir il faut véritablement donné
il y ait abandonné il faut qu'on relit
absolument balisait de l'étape avec
ce qui se passe sur le terrain eh bien
merci merci beaucoup à tous les deux on
va revenir à nouveau salle des
conférences pour rejoindre alexandre
retour avec vous et bien sûr l'actualité
dans l'hémicycle le projet de loi ce
séparatisme et alexandre vous être avec
stéphane pieds-noirs sénateurs l air de
maine et loire qui a vu plusieurs de ces
amendements adoptés sur les universités
ailleurs hier c'est d'ailleurs un point
sur lequel il est rapporteur sur ce
texte
hewitt a un mal hier soir les sénateurs
ont voté de nombreuses mesures pour
renforcer la neutralité religieuse à
l'université avec et bien par exemple
l'interdiction de prière dans les salles
de classes à l'université
stéphane pieds noirs on a modifié la loi
mais au final est ce que on la modifie
pour une réalité qui est tangible ou
alors elle est allée marginal oui les
deux à la fois elle est à la fois
tangibles et marginal tangible parce que
j'ai eu des éléments qui me permettent
d'affirmer ce que j'ai dit hier en
séance à savoir qu' on observe des
atteintes à la laïcité une quarantaine
par an qui sont concentrés sur un petit
nombre d'universités donc c'est marginal
bien sûr je comprends que pour le grand
public
on ne conçoivent pas que la réalité de
cette chose là
en revanche pour les universités sur
lesquels ça se concentre c'est une vraie
réalité de la vie de beaucoup il faut
refuser l'inacceptable inacceptable
c'est que des pratiques religieuses
l'exercice du culte se déroule dans les
salles de cours dans les amphis mais
aussi dans les annexes dans les couloirs
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
voté cet amendement hier que j'ai
d'ailleurs pour lesquelles j'ai proposé
une nouvelle rédaction plus complète
hier en séance la majorité sénatoriale a
également interdit les listes dites
communautariste aux élections étudiantes
là encore eh bien ça cache une vraie
réalité il ya du communautarisme au sein
des syndicats étudiants
oui par l'exemple nous avons des
exemples récents sur sur une forme de
séparatisme qui existe et d'obstruction
sur les sur le lieu de
deux débats qu'elle à l'université
s'agissant des élections
nous avons pris cette disposition encore
une fois ça ne vise pas un phénomène
extrêmement répandu néanmoins nous
devons nous prémunir m comme j'avais dit
la semaine dernière des barbelés sur des
tendances qui pourraient des tentations
qui pourraient exister
nous devons refuser comme pour les élus
les autres élections des listes
communautariste ça fait partie des
dispositions un peu forte un peu musclé
nous avons voté alors là ce sont des
mesures prises dans un contexte actuel
de polémiques notamment autour du
syndicat étudiant unef et ce que l'unef
peut être considérée comme un syndicat
communautariste
après ces réunions nominaux mixte
interdite aux blancs adhérence et
communautaristes en tout cas son
interdiction de d'accès aux réunions
réunion n'ont mis que tel que tel que ça
a été déclinée c'est tout à fait
contestable moi je ne suis pas pour la
dissolution de lunettes par exemple je
poursuis pour des sanctions ski le ski
me propose qu'ils revendiquent est
totalement inacceptable et doit faire
l'objet de poursuites
néanmoins on nous nous devons conserver
ce syndicat merci stéphane gay noir
d'avoir répondu à mes questions et on va
aller tout de suite dans la tribune de
presse de l'hémicycle avec vous steve
jours d'un style quel est le programme
de cette séance de questions d'actualité
quel est l'avenir du secteur aérien en
france et l'un des thèmes qui va animer
ces d'après midi cette séance
d'actualité au gouvernement
on a appris lundi bien que le groupe air
france allait bien être recapitalisées
par l'état ça c'est à la suite du feu
vert donné par bruxelles au plan proposé
par le gouvernement recapitalisation
contre cession de créneaux horaires à
des concurrents à l'aéroport d'orly le
problème est bien c'est que les
syndicats s'inquiètent de cette cession
de créneaux horaires les syndicats
craignent que ces créneaux soit a cédé
bien des compagnies low cost est donc
qu'à terme ce soit des milliers
d'emplois qu'ils soient menacés toujours
selon ces mêmes syndicats sur ce point
le gouvernement va tenter de rassurer
vous l'avez entendu la séance est
ouverte on se retrouve juste après pour
le débrief a tout de suite
il est donc adoptée sous les réserves
d'usagé
monsieur le premier ministre bienvenue
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues l'ordre du jour appelle
les questions d'actualité au
gouvernement
notre science et retransmise en direct
sur public sénat et sur notre site
internet
chacun sera attentif au respect des uns
et des autres et au respect du temps de
parole je vais donner maintenant la
parole à notre collègue bernard fialaire
pour le groupe du rassemblement
démocratique et social européen vous
avez la parole mon cher collègue
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre
jeudi dernier le président de la
république s'est entretenu avec le
principe le prince héritier d'arabie
saoudite
mohammed bin salman l'elysée indique que
les deux dirigeants partagent la même
volonté de voir se former un
gouvernement crédible au liban pour
sortir ce pays de la crise et juge que
sa formation reste la condition à la
mobilisation d'une aide internationale
à plus long terme or depuis octobre
dernier
les échanges entre le premier ministre
saad hariri et le président michel aoun
n'ont toujours pas permis de former un
gouvernement alors que le liban traverse
une crise économique très grave chute de
la livre libanaise hyperinflation
explosion de la provoc la pauvreté
défaillance dans le système de santé et
risque de panne énergétique généralisée
c'est cette faillite de l'état qui avait
alimenté les manifestations du peuple
réclamant le départ de toute la classe
politique et le refus des ingérences
étrangères en particulier iranienne le
système politique est en effet empêtré
dans ses querelles confessionnelles et
la corruption et reste complètement
dépassé par la crise économique
les résultats de l' enquête sur la cause
de l'explosion se font attendre et il
est difficile pour la justice libanaise
de travailler en toute transparence à
l'abri de toute interférence politique
lors de son dernier déplacement à
beyrouth en septembre dernier le
président avait posé la formation d'un
gouvernement légitime
une condition à la mobilisation de
l'aide internationale en particulier
dans le cadre des conférences sèvres en
lien avec la banque mondiale laure n'est
elle pas venue de faire preuve de plus
de fermeté pour y parvenir est ainsi
portée urgemment une aide secourable est
nécessaire à la population libanaise
aujourd'hui monsieur le ministre comment
comptez vous renforcer la pression de la
communauté internationale et en
particulier de l'union européenne pour
soutenir le peuple libanais pour vous
répondre la parole est à monsieur le
ministre de l'europe et des affaires
étrangères monsieur le drian
monsieur le sénateur fialaire vous avez
décrit la situation et les réalités du
liban je compléterai votre description
en vous signalant que le produit
intérieur brut du liban a été ramené à
celui des années 2000 cette crise n'est
pas lié à une catastrophe naturelle
cette crise a des responsables bien
identifiés
car face à cette situation les forces
politiques libanaises refuse de
s'entendre sur la composition d'un
gouvernement leur aveuglement est un
crime de non assistance à pays en danger
et pourtant vous l'avez rappelé des
engagements avaient été pris le 1er
septembre dernier y compris sur la
totalité des réformes à entreprendre que
chacun connaît l'obstruction délibéré à
toute perspective de sortie de crise et
en particulier de la part de certains
acteurs du système politique libanais
par des demandes inconsidérés et des
demandes d'un autre temps doit cesser je
voudrais vous informer monsieur le
sénateur mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs et sénatrices que des
propositions concrètes sont en cours
d'élaboration à l'encontre de ceux là
même qui ont abandonné l'intérêt j
ayral au profit de leurs intérêts
personnels et si certains acteurs
politiques libanais ne prennent pas
leurs responsabilités nous n'hésiterons
pas à prendre les nôtres à cet égard les
décisions qu'ils prendront qu'ils
refuseront de prendre au cours des
prochains jours seront déterminantes
c'est le message que le présent dans
blick et moi même avons passé aux
principaux responsables libanais hier la
france pour sa part continue de se tenir
aux côtés du peuple libanais nous savons
que le liban peut compter sur des
libanaises et des libanais de valeur au
sein de la société civile qui ont à
coeur de travailler sincèrement à
l'édification du liban de demain nous
entendons donc travailler avec ceux qui
portent l'espoir et l'avenir de ce pays
et nous ne ménagerons pas nos efforts à
cette fin merci monsieur le ministre
la parole est à notre collègue jacques
fernique pour le groupe écologie
solidarité territoriale la parole merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre la question que je vous pose au
nom du groupe écologiste concerne le
secteur aérien
elle ne portera pas pour autant sur le
sort d'une subvention de 8000 euros à
l'aéro club du poitou ou sur le péril
vert d'une police des rêves d'enfants je
crois que suffisamment de ministres ont
surréagi là dessus et continueront sans
doute à le faire pour les prochains
épisodes de la série
haro sur les écolos n'ont mama question
plus sérieusement porte sur le
nécessaire soutien au secteur
aéronautique qui est un des plus
durement frappée par la crise mondiale
provoquée par la pandémie
le trafic et les recettes se sont
effondrées les commandes d'avions neufs
ont brutalement plongé donc les soutiens
publics les crédits de relance sont bien
sûr nécessaires
'l'annonce dimanche d'un abondement de 4
milliards d' aide pour air france
participe de cet effort public
il serait cependant illusoire de penser
qu'il suffit de milliards payés par les
contribuables pour assurer un avenir
durable de l'aérien celui ci ne peut
s'exonérer d'une transition qui
répondent aux enjeux sociaux économiques
et climatiques
quatre cent mille
emplois sont en jeu pour l'ensemble du
secteur on peut pas accepter le
délitement et les suppressions
programmées
quelle action forte de l'état pour la
sauvegarde des emplois et les
reconversions le climat aussi et surtout
est en jeu un aller retour paris new
york c'est une tonne de co2 par passager
alors que notre pays s'est engagé à ce
que chacun d'entre nous pour l'ensemble
de son bilan carbone passe sous les 2
tonnes par an d'ici 2050
quelle stratégie pour la décarbonation
du secteur il y a les progrès techniques
mais aussi les reports quand c'est
possible vers d'autres modes de
transport moins émetteur est il viable
de s'en remettre à l'initiative privée
les acteurs du secteur ne faut-il pas
envisager des changements structurels
monsieur le ministre quel
conditionnalité climatique quels
conditionnalité sociale pour ces aides
vont répondre la parole et au ministre
de l'économie des finances et de la
relance monsieur bruno le maire monsieur
le président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur si je me
permettais je vous dirais que vous ne
manquez pas d'air
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
parce que attaqué autant que vous le
faites le transport aérien tout en
demandant d'un autre côté de le soutenir
sa demande pas d'air quant aux reproches
que vous nous faites d'avoir attaqué
collectivement la maire de poitiers vous
permettrait de confirmer que je ne
souhaite pas et que personne ici ne
souhaite que les responsables politiques
s'occupent des rêves de nos enfants que
ce soit bien dit une fois pour toutes
[Applaudissements]
mais je veux vous rassurer et je veux
vous rassurer votre collègue de poitiers
je veux rassurer tous les verts nous
continuerons à soutenir massivement et
durablement le transport aérien les pme
qui travaillent dans l'aérien le secteur
aéronautique airbus
toute l'industrie française qui fait
notre excellent sur le transport aérien
et nous allons le faire avec cette
ambition qui est d'accélérer la
décarbonation notre industrie parce que
oui nous pouvons être la première nation
est le premier continent au monde à
proposer un avion zéro carbone
fonctionnant à l'hydrogène
c'est ça notre ambition plutôt que de
laisser des avions et les emplois avec
cloués au sol
notre ambition c'est d'avoir plus de
carburant décarbonés dans les avions qui
volent notre ambition c'est de réduire
l'utilisation de l'avion et nous avons
je le rappelle demandé à air france de
supprimer toutes les lignes lorsqu'il
existe une alternative par le train à
moins de 2h30
c'est ça notre ambition par l'aérien pas
clouer les avions au sol
mais avoir des avions plus propre plus
compétitifs créateurs d'emplois et qui
soutiennent notre industrie
merci monsieur ministre la parole dont
la parole est à notre collègue jean
louis lagourgue
pour le groupe les indépendants
république et territoires la parole bien
si monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre le secteur aérien français se
trouvent parmi les secteurs les plus
durement impactée par la crise sanitaire
actuelle dans ce contexte l'état su
prendre les décisions permettant de
garantir la pérennité d air france et de
corsair je souhaite pour ma part attirer
votre attention sur celle d'air austral
compagnie française de l'océan indien
basée à la réunion et qui contribue le
peu plus de 30 ans au rayonnement des
ailes françaises la zone sud de l'océan
indien depuis le mois de janvier 2020
cette compagnie régionale a subi une
chute dramatique de son chiffre
d'affaires de près de 55 % ainsi qu'une
dégradation de ses résultats
face à cette situation un plan d'action
a été mis en place mais il ne suffit pas
l'intervention de l'état est désormais
cruciale pour assurer la survie de ce
fleuron qui est l'une des plus
importantes entreprises françaises de la
foux entreprises la france le sang
indien et qui fait vivre plus de 1000
familles à la réunion il est urgent de
maintenir des capacités trésorerie d'air
austral un financement d'état de 30
millions d'euros était prévue à ce jour
il semble que les discussions n'est pas
aboutie or le temps presse et il est
urgent d'agir
le second niveau d'intervention vise à
nous interroger sur l'attitude agressive
de la compagnie ea france chez les
marchés outre-mer et aux conséquences
dramatiques que sa stratégie peut avoir
c'est l'existence même des rostrales un
succès sur les autres compagnies qui
desservent la réunion
cette situation menace gravement le
futur d'air austral je souhaiterais donc
savoir monsieur le ministre si le
gouvernement est en mesure aujourd'hui
de rassurer les dirigeants et salariés
d'air austral sur un total soutiennent
l'état pour la sauvegarde et la
pérennité de cette compagnie par
ailleurs
quelles mesures comptez vous prendre
pour protéger air austral des velléités
de la france quand vous répondre la
parole et au ministre de l'économie des
finances et de la relance monsieur bruno
le maire monsieur le sénateur je veux
vous confirmer que l'état français
soutiendra air austral il soutiendra
cette compagnie qui est vital pour l'île
de la réunion et représente comme nous
l'a indiqué plusieurs centaines
d'emplois d'abord avec un prêt garanti
par l'état de 30 millions d'euros
c'est le signe de l'engagement de l'état
aux côtés d'air austral
toujours sur le soutien financier j'ai
eu l'occasion de m'entretenir avec le
président de la région didier robert il
ya quelques instants qui m'a confirmé
que la sematra apporterait également une
aide financière très importante à air
austral c'est un deuxième soutien
financier sur lequel la compagnie pourra
compter enfin il y a le soutient la
caisse des dépôts et consignations qui
va apporter cinq millions d'euros à la
compagnie et je suis disposé à demander
à la caisse des dépôts et consignations
d'apporter un soutien financier
supplémentaire au delà de ces 5 millions
d'euros à air austral parce que je
partage votre avis air austral est vital
pour lille vital pour la concurrence est
vitale pour les emplois qu'elles
représentent sur l'île j'ai eu moi même
l'occasion de voir à quel point c'était
deux compagnies étaient une compagnie de
grande qualité quand il était encore
simple de se rendre sur l'île de la
réunion
ensuite il ya les relations avec air
france là dessus je veux pas laisser
planer d'ambiguïté
air france ne prendra pas de
participation dans air austral
ça n'est pas possible notamment depuis
le soutien que nous avons apportées à
air france air france doit se
reconstituer gagner en compétitivité
la france ne peut pas investir dans le
même temps dans air austral
en revanche je pense qu'il est essentiel
qu'il y ait un accord qui soit conclu
entre air france et air austral la
répartition des créneaux je sais que les
discussions sont difficiles donc je suis
prêt à aider à ce que ces discussions se
poursuivent et aboutissent de manière
constructive pas de manière agressive ou
hostiles entre air france et air austral
je suis convaincu que nous arriverons à
trouver un terrain d'entente en sans
merci
la parole est à notre collègue laurent
duplomb pour le groupe est républicain
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre l'agriculture le monde agricole
attend vos orientations pour la nouvelle
pac avec un mélange d'inquiétude et de
désabusement de désabusement car jamais
leur profession n'a été autant
incomprise et caricaturés d'inquiétude
car les agriculteurs ne comprennent plus
quel chemin on veut leur faire prendre
avant de trancher
il faut revenir à l'essentiel qu'est ce
qu'une bonne politique agricole commune
c'est d'abord monsieur le ministre une
politique pour une agriculture
souveraine non dépendante des
importations d'autres pays une politique
agricole qui favorise le pouvoir d'achat
des citoyens tout en soutenant le revenu
des agriculteurs par des aides du
premier pilier
c'est également une politique en faveur
de notre compétitivité qui n'abandonne
pas notre vocation exportatrice
c'est une politique de solidarité entre
les filières notamment par la correction
des handicaps naturels est extrait sec à
la volonté des hommes les i ch hands off
ted garantie à l'euro près pour par le
budget national
c'est une politique qui a inventé
l'agriculture de demain en la faisant
évoluer en respectant le temps long des
cultures sans ajouter de contraintes
supplémentaires à nos agriculteurs
à ce stade la politique agricole commune
que vous en vise à envisager ne va pas
au bout et c'est ce qui inquiète les
filières écouter leurs attentes
plus de transferts entre pilier c'est
plus de distorsions de distorsion de
concurrence entre états membres
en france le taux doit être tout au plus
maintenu à son niveau actuel les échos
régime ne doivent pas devenir une usine
à gaz
ils doivent répondre à des conditions
simples et embrasser un maximum
d'agriculteurs
l'enjeu du couplage aussi nous posez pas
les filières en sacrifiant la filière
bovine pour la filière protéines
joueront les complémentarités maintenait
les enveloppes des aides
couplés pour nos éleveurs les
agriculteurs veulent des réponses
claires à une question simple la pac que
vous préparez à quoi ressemble-t-elle
pour vous répondre la parole et au
ministre de l'agriculture et de
l'alimentation monsieur lui lit je
l'avais la parole merci beaucoup
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur du plan avant de répondre à
votre question permettez moi d'abord
d'exprimer toute notre solidarité
républicaine vis-à-vis du monde agricole
qui comme vous l'avez vu depuis
plusieurs jours subi des vagues de froid
très importante un peu partout dans
notre pays avec des conséquences
absolument dramatiques sur plusieurs de
nos filières ce qui renvoie d'ailleurs à
une question dont nous avons beaucoup
parlé qui cette question de l'assurance
de l'assurance récolte dans le monde
agricole
la question que vous me posez monsieur
le sénateur du plomb et celle de la
vision de la politique agricole commune
je partage beaucoup des points que vous
avez évoquées et vous le savez pour moi
il ya quatre principaux objectifs sur
cette politique agricole commune
d'abord c'est une question d'agriculture
compétitive une agriculture compétitive
elle doit permettre à nos agriculteurs
de vivre de leur travail cela veut dire
un maintien du premier pilier
cela veut dire également un écho régime
accessible à chacun le deuxième élément
c'est que cette agriculture elle doit
être plus souveraine lutter contre un
certain nombre de dépendance dépendance
vis-à-vis des importations
vous connaissez notre combat pour moins
d'importations protéines qui vient
d'amérique du sud c'est autant de
déforestation qu'on importe alors même
que nos champs de protéines aujourd'hui
sont en décroissance dans notre pays le
troisième élément c'est une agriculture
des territoires qui prend en compte les
spécificités territoriales
ça veut dire une prise en compte total
de li chn vous l'avez dit ça veut dire
également de reconnaître des
spécificités comme celle des zones
fermée hier et enfin le dernier élément
c'est une agriculture tourné vers la
qualité la qualité dans les transitions
agro écologiques et je le redis l'écho
régime je fais mien vos propos ne doit
pas être une usine à gaz et doit être
inclusif accompagnant les agriculteurs
cela veut dire aussi que les aides
couplées qui aide à cette création de
valeur et à cette qualité
elle ne doit pas opposer des filières
comme vous l'avez dit et là aussi j'en
suis absolument convaincu
juste pour conclure tout cela se fait
dans le cadre de la concertation la
discussion et permettez moi en guise de
conclusion de vous remercier
personnellement parce que je connais
votre implication comme celle des
sénateurs sur ce sujet et nos éclairages
sont très précieux
merci la parole est maintenant au
président laurent lafon pour le groupe
de l'union centriste le président merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre la semaine dernière le
président de la république a annoncé la
reprise des cours à distance pour
l'ensemble des élèves de france du 6
avril jusqu'au 9 avril date de début des
vacances de printemps les collégiens et
les lycéens eux resteront à distance au
moins jusqu'au début du mois de mai hier
depuis leur habitation ce sont donc 12
millions d'élèves qui ont essayé de se
connecter
malheureusement deux séries de bugs
informatiques les ont privés d'école en
tout cas temporairement celui de ma
classe à la maison du cned qui permet
d'assurer les cours en visio et celui
des espaces numériques de travail locaux
les ent qui permettent de charger les
cours et devoirs
vingt-quatre heures après les raisons de
ces difficultés restent floues pour les
ent c'est notre fleuron national
ovh qui a été accusée d'avoir failli
mais celui ci dément d'autant plus que
certains ent sont hébergés par amazon
pour le cned c'est l'explication d'une
cyber attaque par déni de service qui a
été avancé soit exactement la même que
celle déjà subie en mars 2020 cette
situation montre monsieur le ministre
que manifestement nous n'étions pas
prêts à reprendre les cours à distance
alors même que nous avions eu plusieurs
mois pour nous y préparer
vous ne serez pas surpris par conséquent
des questions que je vais
vous posez pourriez vous nous expliquer
les raisons précises de ces bugs et nous
rassurer sur le fait qu'elles sont
définitivement résolu deuxième question
suite à des attaques subies par le cned
l'an passé quelles ont été les mesures
prises pour éviter qu'elles ne se
reproduisent
l'état at-il dialoguer avec les
collectivités pour qu'elles
redimensionne les hébergements des ent
et enfin de nombreux professeurs sont
obligés de contourner ses difficultés en
ayant recours à des plateformes comme
celle de windows ou de google
avez vous un chiffrage précis sur
l'étendue du phénomène
merci quand vous répondront la parole et
au ministre de l'éducation nationale de
la jeunesse et des sports monsieur le
ministre vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur laffont en effet depuis hier la
france est rentrée dans l'enseignement à
distance massif elle l'était déjà de
manière hybride vous le savez notamment
pour les lycées depuis un an il s'est
passé beaucoup de choses il ya eu
préparation importante des professeurs
en particulier la formation à distance
ils étaient tous très fière et je
regrette d'autant plus les phénomènes
qui se sont passées qui sont des
phénomènes techniques sur le plan
pédagogique les professeurs étaient
prêts en matière informatique comme dans
d'autres matières l'éducation nationale
et responsable surtout des enjeux de
contenu les enjeux qu'on peut qualifier
de tuyaux relève d'autres compétences
hier ça s'est passé correctement pour
certains ça s'est passé
mal voire très mal pour d'autres et là
où ça s'est passé mal c'est dans
certaines parties du territoire
pourquoi parce que les environnements
numériques de travail je répondrais sur
le cned ensuite en effet n'ont pas pu
supporter l'afflux immédiat de des
quelques millions d'élèves et leurs
familles qui ont été sur internet au
même moment
ceci alors même que la semaine dernière
nous avions une interlocution évidemment
avec les régions qui sont responsables
de cela et qu'il nous était assuré que
dans leurs relations avec les
prestataires les choses étaient préparés
cela nous renvoie donc aux prestataires
je n'ai aucunement pointe et ovh preuve
j'en profite pour le dire j'ai dû
justice hier au début de la crise que
les premiers éléments que nous avions
c'était que fameux incendie qui avait vu
avec des conséquences indirectes sur
tout cela et c'est vrai
parce que le report sur différents
opérateurs en france fait que on
constate et je le déplore que certains
opérateurs n'ont pas la puissance
technique pour suivre ce n'est pas de la
compétence de l'éducation nationale je
le rappelle et j'observe que certains
qui sont prompts à mettre les
responsabilités sur l'éducation
nationale doivent aujourd'hui surtout
nous expliquer ce qui s'est passé c'est
donc ce que nous saurons dans le détail
tout au long des prochains temps et dans
l'immédiat nous travaillons surtout au
rétablissement des choses c'est ce qui
se passe en lien avec les régions et en
lien avec les opérateurs concernés sur
le cned il ya eu des cyberattaques j'y
répondrai peut-être encore tout à
l'heure et c'est nous vous avons
d'ailleurs déposé plainte pour ces
cyber-attaques probablement certaines
depuis l'hexagone d'autres depuis
l'étranger mais ces sites hébert
attaques ont été extrêmement importante
au moment même où des centaines de
milliers de comptes étaient par ailleurs
créé pour faire face à la situation
je compléterai ma réponse est évidemment
dans d'autres contextes je vous remercie
monsieur le président la faune la parole
un autre collègue fabien gay pour le
groupe communiste républicain citoyen et
collèges il avait la parole
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre vous avez annoncé une nouvelle
aide de 4 milliards d'euros et une
montagne et une montée au capital d'air
france klm à hauteur de 29,9 pour cent
permettant à l'état de redevenir le
premier actionnaire de la compagnie
depuis le début de cette crise nous
n'avons eu de cesse de plaider avec
notre groupe pour des prises de
participation de l'état dans les grandes
entreprises stratégiques
vous ne répondiez que cela était
impossible votre position a
manifestement changé mais vous avez
perdu un an
mais ce soutien air france risque de
coûter cher en contrepartie exigée par
la commission européenne pour les
salariés les usagers
d'abord sur les créneaux qu'air france
va devoir céder à ses concurrents vous
vous féliciter d'avoir obtenu 18 créneau
plutôt que les 24 demandé au départ par
la commission européenne
mais exiger d'une entreprise en
difficulté qu'elles cèdent des créneaux
même peu fréquenté et même à des
compagnies réponde à certaines exigences
fiscales et sociales ce qui n'est pas
l'avis de la commission européenne
cela ne va faire que l'affaiblir
davantage dans l'avenir mais surtout sur
le ministre
la question centrale et avec quelles
ambitions politiques sociales et
environnementales
non on nous au capital cette prise de
participation est l temporaire avec pour
but de nationaliser les pertes puis de
reprivatiser les profits dès que la
situation s'améliorera en faisant payer
l'addition aux salariés ou s'agit-il
d'un engagement pérenne bénéfique à air
france à ses salariés et à ses usagers
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre de l'économie des finances et
de la relance vous avez la parole
mais c'est le sénateur fabien gay seule
chose que je sais c'est que si l'état
français n'ait pas soutenu à france
depuis le premier jour dans cette crise
il n'y aurait plus d'air france à
l'heure où je vous parle donc l'état
français à la demande du premier
ministre à la demande du président de la
république a pris ses responsabilités il
estimé que la france était stratégique
que les 40000 emplois derrière était
stratégique que l'impact sur le tourisme
et sur la capacité à avoir des aéroports
de classe mondiale avec henry et avec
roissy charles de gaulle était
absolument stratégique et donc nous
avons pris cette décision d'un soutien
massif à air france 7 milliards d'euros
4 milliards d'euros de prêts garantis
par l'état
3 milliards d'euros d' avance de l'état
qui viennent d'être en transformer alors
que c'était uniquement pour quatre ans
en participation directe fonds propres
de l'état dans l'entreprise annonce que
j'ai fait hier que nous allions monter
au capital pour un montant qui pourra
aller jusqu'à un milliard d'euros mais
qui fera de l'état français le première
actionnaire d'air france je pense qu'on
ne peut pas avoir deux témoignages plus
clair notre détermination à soutenir
cette compagnie aérienne nationale
il en va de l'indépendance de la france
et notre capacité à peser dans le champ
touristique mondiale oui à des
contreparties côté demandé mais je
rappelle que lufthansa a accepté de
céder 48 créneau en échange du soutien
de l'état allemand à lufthansa
on nous demandait 24 créneau nous en
avons retenu 18 soit 4% des créneaux
d'air france sur orly il me semble que
c'est un accord qui est équilibré et
raisonnable
nous avons également obtenu un point clé
c'est qu'aucune compagnie qui fait du
dumping social ou qui fait du dumping
fiscal ne puissent avoir accès à ces
créneaux aérien qui seront cédés par la
france et croyez moi ce serait très
vigilant sur le respect de cet
engagement qui a été pris par la
commission européenne
quelle est l'ambition de long terme
c'est une excellente question est très
simple faire d'air france la compagnie
la plus respectueuse de l'environnement
de la planète demandèrent france de
renouer avec les bénéfices et d'être une
compagnie compétitifs parce que nous ne
pouvons pas demander aux contribuables
français de soutenir air france à
hauteur de plusieurs milliards d'euros
sans demander en contrepartie car france
renoue avec les bénéfices avec le succès
elle en est capable et elle va y arriver
monsieur guay monsieur le ministre vous
considériez roissy et orly comme
stratégiques c'est pour ça qu'ils aient
encore deux ans vous voulez les
privatiser mais s'ils ont la réponse
pas un mot sur la suppression des 8500
salariés prévue à l'horizon 2022 palm ou
pour les 30000 emplois menacés dans la
zone aéroportuaire de roissy notamment
des sous traitants d'air france
pas un mot sur les salariés d'air france
qui vont rester qui vont devoir rendre
leurs congés ou voir leur salaire gelé
pendant cinq ans et encore une fois
monsieur le ministre vous avez changé
mais pas de dogme vous rester enfermé
dans votre dogme néolibéral qui consiste
à donner de l'argent public pour payer
les licenciements et le massacre social
nous irons il faut d'urgence garantir
les emplois et des critères
environnementaux pour air france je vous
remercie monsieur le président de la
parole est maintenant notre collègue
teva rofritsch pour le groupe du
rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et indépendant vous avez
la parole
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre on apportant un soutien
capillaire d'euros à air france et en
devenant en en devenant le premier
actionnaire l'état réaffirme son
engagement aux côtés de la compagnie et
de ses salariés
c'est une action nécessaire pour
consolider fortement cette entreprise
stratégique pour la france la question
du pass sanitaires
du certificat vert doit également être
tranchée pour offrir plus de visibilité
au secteur
nos compagnies aériennes françaises
régionale soutenue par nos collectivités
territoriales souffre tout autant c'est
le cas d'air tahiti nui qui a dû mettre
en oeuvre un plan d'économies drastique
sans bénéficier de chômage partiel en se
séparant de 17% de ses salariés la
compagnie tout aussi vital en polynésie
française passera difficilement l'année
sans une intervention financière de
l'état et l'été sur la dramatique si les
frontières polynésienne ne sont pas
réouverte au tourisme alors que le
contexte sanitaire et maîtriser là bas à
seize mille kilomètres de paris
monsieur ministre alors qu'à france va
être à juste titre soutenu massivement
que comptez vous faire pour accompagner
nos compagnies aériennes françaises
régionales tout aussi stratégique pour
l'économie de nos territoires
ultramarins tout particulièrement bien
entendu air tahiti nui
on va répondre la parole de toby
l'économie des finances de la relance
bruno le maire vous avez la parole
mais le ch le sénateur nous avons
soutenu air france loin d'ailleurs je le
dis et monsieur guay d'une vision de
libéral parce que la vision néolibérale
à 30% de participation de l'état dans le
capital est là si je puis dire une
nouvelle fois du plomb dans l'ailé
s'agissant des retailles ti nous feront
exactement la même chose
nous avons apporté 60 millions d'euros
de prêts garantis par l'état à air
tahiti
nous avons le dispositif coûts fixes que
nous avons mis en place qui permet de
disposer d'une aide à la prise en charge
des coûts fixes des entreprises qui ont
plus d'un million d'euros de chiffre
d'affaires c'est le cas d'air tahiti à
hauteur de 10 millions d'euros je
souhaite que air tahiti puissent en
bénéficier
ce souhaite également que air tahiti
puisse prendre contact très rapidement
je crois que c'est le cas avec le
shearim et services pour regarder
comment est ce que sur le long terme
nous pouvons garantir la pérennité de
l'entreprise je n'ai pas d'inquiétude
sur la trésorerie d'air tahiti d'ici la
fin de l'année mais je souhaite que
cette compagnie puisse continuer à voler
continuer à desservir les territoires
qu'elle dessert nous avons besoin de
trouver d'autres modalités de soutien
que celles que nous avons déjà mis en
place
j'invite air tahiti à saisir le ciri à
discuter avec nous nous trouvons des
solutions
merci monsieur ministère tête inouï et
je pense a suivi votre réponse ainsi que
toute la polynésie
le secteur du tourisme est vital en
polynésie française des milliers de
familles en vivent
et bien entendu nos francs toutes les
démarches nécessaires selon les
formalités vous venait d'indiquer de
grâce ne laissait pas être traitée nous
y deux côtés merci
la parole est maintenant de notre
collègue us est nourrie pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste et république
président mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le premier
ministre le 11 mars dernier le sénat
examinait la proposition de loi de notre
collègue marie pierre de la gontrie et
du groupe socialistes écologistes et
républicains pour le droit à mourir dans
la dignité
au terme d'un débat de très haute tenue
la proposition de loi a été rejetée de
19 voix au sénat nous en avons pris acte
avec regret ce 8 avril
l'assemblée nationale doit examiner la
proposition de loi donnant le droit à
une fin de vie libre est choisi à
l'initiative du député olivier falorni
quelques députés ont déposé deux mille
trois cents amendements
cette obstruction délibéré empêchera
vraisemblablement l'assemblée nationale
de se prononcer demain et le
gouvernement dans tout ça c'est cette
question que de nombreux français se
posent et nous posent
monsieur le premier ministre mesdames
messieurs les ministres vous le savez
cela fait 40 ans que des françaises et
des français de plus en plus nombreux
aujourd'hui des millions de français
attendent de cette loi il espère cette
loi ils veulent cette loi monsieur le
premier ministre ma question est simple
avez vous prévu de soumettre au
parlement avant la fin du quinquennat un
projet de loi sur la fin de vie
je vous remercie la parole monsieur
drilles attaqué sur le dire le chaos
charge de l'enfance et des familles vous
avez la parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur bourgi le débat sur
les questions relatives à la fin de vie
et aider plus peu au coeur de
l'actualité parlementaire vous l'avez
dit et ces questions-là résonne
probablement tout particulièrement en
cette période
de pandémie qui a vu près de cent mille
de nos concitoyens nous quitter après
l'examen il ya quelques semaines vous
l'avez rappelé dans cet hémicycle de la
proposition de loi portée par la
sénatrice de la gondry c'est au tour de
l'assemblée nationale par le biais de la
proposition de loi de l'hiver falorni de
se prononcer sur ce texte l'aide ses
textes parlementaires sont nombreux à
travailler avec calme rigueur sur ce
sujet complexe
il ya eu la loi classe leonetti
évidemment de 2016 avec ses apports
fondamentaux qui vise à s'opposer à
toute forme d'acharnement thérapeutique
qui vous la possibilité d'interruption
des traitements si ceux ci apparaissent
inutiles ou disproportionnés et ses
avancées sont saluées comme des avancées
déterminantes temps elles ont pu
répondre aux difficultés aux souffrances
de nombreuses personnes de nombreuses
familles aujourd'hui le gouvernement
prend acte de la volonté de certains
parlementaires d'approfondir cadre
juridique il respecte aussi le droit
fondamental constitutionnel
d'amendements la part des députés et la
demande se prononcera pas sur ce qui
peut paraître effectivement aux yeux de
certains à une tentative d'obstruction
mais le gouvernement prend part au débat
il a pris part aux débats en ici même en
mars dernier lorsqu'olivier vers en a
lui même annoncé le lancement à compter
d'avril prochain d'un nouveau plan
national de développement des soins
palliatifs et d'accompagnement de la fin
de vie précédents s'étaient interrompus
en 2019
il fallait le relancer pour prendre en
compte les enjeux de développement de la
prise en charge en ville pour mieux
répondre à la nécessité d'améliorer la
formation initiale et continue de
l'ensemble des professionnels et puis
aussi pour mieux sensibiliser nos
concitoyens à ces questions là qui
doivent être mieux informés par exemple
sur la directive sur les directives
anticipées
nous voulons donc que le débat se tienne
sur des bases éclairé il nous semble
aujourd'hui que les consultations les
contributions de la part d'experts
doivent encore être poursuivie afin de
pouvoir avoir un débat éclairé sur ce
sujet monsieur venger
monsieur le ministre vous le savez bien
la dmd et les millions de français qui
soutiennent cette revendication souhaite
et la loi sur la fin de vie et le
développement des soins palliatifs vous
le savez il y a trente ans département
dans notre pays où il n'ya aucune unité
de soins palliatifs développer les soins
palliatifs n'exonère pas le gouvernement
de réfléchir au vote d'une loi sur la
fin de vie vous le savez monsieur le
premier ministre mesdames messieurs les
ministres la noblesse de la politique
c'est d'assurer les débats difficiles
avec responsabilité et courage votre
réponse le seul ministre me laisse à
penser que pour la responsabilité vous
vous défausser pour pratiquer l esquive
et pour la loi sur la fin de vie j'ai
bien compris que pour l'actuel
gouvernement
le courage politique ce n'était pas pour
maintenant et je le regrette
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
renaud le lieu pour le groupe l'est
républicain
cette président monsieur le ministre de
l'éducation nationale nous nous tenons
prêts c'est par ces mots comment à
d'août dernier vous répondiez au journal
du dimanche à une question relative au
fiasco technologique qui s'est passé
lors du premier confinement le 16 mars
2020 et où il ya eu un plantage
phénoménal qui fait que tout simplement
l'école à la maison n'avait pas
fonctionné lors du premier confinement
vous aviez alors évoqué de soi disant tu
attaques informatiques venues de russie
on se demande bien quel pirate
informatique russe avait comme objectif
de venir voler les cours de maths 2 cm
cette semaine 12 millions 400 mille
élèves étaient concernés par l'école à
la maison les enseignants étaient près
les parents aussi les élèves des
français de l'étranger aussi qui suivent
des écoles des cours à distance et là
nouveau fiasco
le système du cned ne fonctionne pas
avec ma classe à la maison ent pronote
tous ces systèmes sont en carafe
alors vous évoquez effectivement ovh et
son incendie
le pdg de vh cloud lui-même a
immédiatement démenti puis vous évoquez
encore comme l'année dernière de soi
disant des attaques informatiques
la réalité est bien différente vous
aviez un an pour vous préparer un an de
préparation la réalité c'est tout
simplement monsieur le ministre que vous
n'étiez pas prêts et donc ma question
elle est la suivante comment vous la
prétendue start up nation est portée en
étendard par emmanuel macron peut
justifier un tel fiasco
pour vous répondre la parole et crise de
l'éducation nationale de la jeunesse et
des sports
seul entière merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur vous choisissez de
prendre un ton polémique sur un sujet
technique c'est votre droit
votre votre petite boutade sur le sur
les cyber attaques russes montrent à
quel point vous ignorez le sujet mais
vous l'ignorez complètement parce que
des attaques russes
il y en a en permanence et sur les
sujets les plus anodins donc si vous ne
savez pas ça vous avez du mal à savoir
le reste et je vais vous expliquer le
reste la première chose c'est ce que je
disais ben renseignez vous sur les cyber
attaques russes sont renseignez vous sur
ce sujet et on verra si vous pouvez
faire des boutades tous les pays du
monde sont menacées par ce type de cyber
attaques y compris les infrastructures
d'éducation évidemment évidemment et
c'est en effet une partie des choses qui
se sont passées hier vous donner un tour
polémique par exemple en disant que lors
du premier confinement l'enseignement à
distance n'a pas marché c'est vrai qu'il
ya eu des problèmes de tuyaux l'année
dernière au début ça a duré un jour ou
deux et ensuite ça s'est amélioré et on
peut que rendre hommage aux enseignants
qui ont très bien réussi beaucoup de
choses en la matière toutes les enquêtes
montrent 75% de taux de satisfaction des
parents bien sûr il ya eu des
imperfections bien il ya du bien sûr il
ya eu des choses qui n'ont pas marché
mais c'est totalement je dirais
antipatriotique que de nier ce qui s'est
passé de positif à ce moment là deuxième
deuxième assertion de votre part le fait
que nous ne serions pas prêt là aussi
c'est une insulte aux enseignants qui
étaient touche près hier et je l' ai dit
tout à l'heure aux sénateurs la faune il
était près ce qui n'a pas marché c'est
en effet les tuyaux comme on dit ces
tuyaux
alors je vous le répète très clairement
ne sont pas de la compétence de
l'éducation nationale ce sont les
environnements du traîneau mais c'est un
fait il faut le savoir si vous ne le
savez pas c'est un problème
cela relève des régions et des
départements donc en effet la semaine
dernière les collectivités locales nous
ont dit qu'elles étaient prêtes
certaines l'était et d'ailleurs
l'enseignement à distance s'est bien
passé pour une bonne partie du pays air
sur toute une série de régions ça n'a
pas été le cas
c'est en train d'être réparé
actuellement et j'ai bonne confiance
pour le que le saas rétablisse aussi
bien aujourd'hui comme nous constatons
déjà que demain et après demain donc de
grâce ne faisons pas de polémiques
inutiles
parlons de façon informé du sujet et oui
l'éducation nationale a énormément
travaillé sur ces sujets depuis un an et
ne font pas injure ou encore des
personnes qui ont travaillé dans ce sens
vous remercie monsieur le ministre
malheureusement votre réponse ne
convainc personne
le président de la république a dit aux
députés de la république en marche
soyez fiers d'être des amateurs ce soir
vous devez être fiers de vous
la parole
et à notre collègue michael vale pour le
gros choc chaliche écologistes et
républicains
merci merci monsieur le président ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'économie
j'y associe l'ensemble des sénateurs
socialistes de nouvelles aquitaine et je
sais nos collègues de la vienne mobilisé
sur le sujet qui suit en 1979
renault installe ses activités de
fonderie fonte et aluminium à ingrandes
dans la vienne en 2019
quarante ans plus tard après être passé
entre les mains de différents groupes et
tout en ayant conservé renault comme
principal donneur d'ordre les deux
branches fonte et aluminium en grande
difficulté sont cédés au groupe gfg
alliance et sa filiale liberty 40 ans
d'une mondialisation loi d'être heureuse
car le châtellerault des comptes depuis
quelques années ces pertes d'emplois par
centaines
aujourd'hui en dépit du soutien du
gouvernement à la reprise par gmc
liberty en 2019
les deux branches courte à nouveau un
grand risque de disparition côté fonte
si rien n'est fait ce sont 2 188
salariés qui seront sans emploi en juin
et sans garantie sur leurs indemnités
puisque nous avons appris récemment que
green seal l'organisme de financement de
gmg avait fait faillite
derrière ces sigles et ces grandes
manoeuvres de multinationales il y à
ingrandes des familles dans le désarroi
côté aluminium la même menace plane avec
un risque de non paiement des salaires
dès le mois prochain
sans parler du plan garantis par l'état
de 18 millions d'euros qui a tout
bonnement disparu et dans quelles poches
monsieur le ministre ma question est la
suivante la france at elle une politique
industrielle et le souci de ses ouvriers
si oui quelles sont les perspectives
pour le secteur de la fonderie dépendant
de grandes entreprises donneurs d'ordre
dont l'état lui même est actionnaire
[Applaudissements]
l'ampl sur le maire de la parole on oui
monsieur le sénateur le gouvernement et
la france en général à une politique
industrielle a le souci de ses salariés
alsh aussi de ses ouvriers
quand nous avons appris les difficultés
financières de liberty la première
décision que nous avons prise avec le
premier ministre c'est d'apporter un
soutien de 20 millions d'euros à l'
usine à ce qu'au val dans le nord de la
france et l ensemble à ce qu'au val
hayange pour que l'usiné puisse
continuer à produire son acier et les
rails qui vont servir ensuite à la sncf
et je rappelle que sans le soutien de
l'état à ce qu'au val aurait disparu à
ce qu'on valait rester debout parce que
nous sommes intervenus
s'agissant des deux fonderies vous avez
deux fonderies très différentes mais
parfaitement 10 chacune de près de 300
emplois l'une fait des pièces en fonte
la fermeture du site sur les pièces en
fonte a été actée hélas à la fin de
l'année parce qu'il n'avait pas de
débouchés pour les pièces en fonte
tout simplement parce que les moteurs
thermiques spam x comme x none x none x
none x none x none x none x none x none
x none x none x none x none x none x
x none x none x xxx xxx xx xxx xx xxx en
aluminium celle là pour moi
elles ont de l'avenir et elles doivent
être préservées et nous ferons le
nécessaire pour garantir une activité et
un avenir aux fonderies du poitou
dans le volet aluminium parce que nous
estimons qu'il ya un marché
il y à des débouchés et qu'il n'y a
aucune raison que les fonderies du
poitou dans le volet aluminium puisse
être pénalisé par la situation
financière du groupe liberty auquel
elles appartiennent depuis plusieurs
mois de manière plus générale pour vous
montrer que nous avons une stratégie il
ya évidemment un sujet de transition du
véhicule thermique vers le
q électrique avec des conséquences sur
des milliers d'emplois dans notre pays
je tiendrai dans les semaines prochaines
au ministère de l'économie et des
finances une réunion avec l'ensemble des
acteurs concernés organisations
syndicales organisations patronales
représentants du secteur industriel pour
regarder l'avenir des fonderies en
france et des milliers de salariés qui
vont avec les accompagner les soutenir
et assurer la transition
c'est ça avoir une politique
industrielle ambitieuse pour la france
monsieur vallée merci monsieur le
président ça ne répond pas à la question
de savoir s'il y a la garantie des
indemnités pour les ouvriers du secteur
fonte
j'ajouterai à vous entendre monsieur le
ministre on peut se demander à quoi cela
sert d'avoir un état actionnaire de
grands groupes comme chez renault à 15%
quand le grand groupe ne manifeste
aucune exigence de patriotisme
économique en dessous 30 est en plus
assez en france
le patriotisme économique n'étant pas un
gros mot il ya donc deux urgences
retourner sur le terrain au contact des
ouvriers d'une part et savoir où sont
passés les millions du plan garantis par
l'état d'autre part c'est le seul en
même temps qu'ils pourraient montrer un
peu de témoignages de sympathie aux
ouvriers la parole est maintenant notre
collègue patricia de vastes pour le
groupe les républiques là
le son président mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresser au ministre des
solidarités de la santé dont je regrette
l'absence selon la dgs seule une moitié
des professionnels de santé a reçu au
moins une injection de vaccin anti
qu'ovide alors que l'ensemble des
soignants il est éligible
c'est une priorité au regard du rôle
qu'ils remplissent dans la bataille
sanitaire qui est la nôtre pour un
soignant se faire vacciner est conforme
à l'éthique de la profession et
s'apparente à une obligation pour
protéger nos plus fragiles ces
fondamentaux doivent s'appliquer
d'autant plus que la vaccination diminue
considérablement les chaînes de
transmission du virus
pour mémoire les personnels et les
étudiants des professions médicales et
paramédicales sont d'ores et déjà soumis
à une obligation de vaccination qui
varient en fonction de leur lieu
d'exercice ou de la nature de leurs
activités
dans cet esprit et au regard du contexte
le ministre de la santé a pelé
naturellement dernièrement à la
vaccination de tous les soignants contre
lakovic 19
tout comme le conseil de l'ordre des
médecins selon l'académie de médecine
la pandémie que nous vivons a provoqué
la crise sanitaire et économique la plus
grave depuis la seconde guerre mondiale
et a entraîné une hausse sans précédent
des infections nosocomiales le devoir
d'exemplarité s'impose il agira
positivement sur la confiance des
français dans la vaccination tout en
confortant leur reconnaissance envers
une corporation qui n'a jamais failli
alors que les français sont une nouvelle
fois soumis à un confinement
que compte faire le gouvernement
concernant la vaccination insuffisante
des soignants dans un contexte qui s'est
lourdement aggravé et où vacciner est
notre priorité
au secrétaire d'état abri attaqué je
suis ministre
merci monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice sur les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice
je crois que je partage à peu près
l'ensemble des propos que vous avez
tenus et notamment sur la nécessité
impérieuse de la part de nos soignants
d'accéder à la vaccination qui leur est
effectivement proposé de façon
prioritaire je vais vous répondre
spécifiquement sur cet aspect là avant
cela permettez moi peut-être d'en
profiter puisqu'il n'a pas il n'en a pas
été question encore aujourd'hui nous
apporter quelques éléments de réponse à
la stratégie de vaccination globale qui
s'accélère dans notre pays la france
n'est pas en retard contrairement à ce
qu'un député que vous connaissez bien a
pu affirmer puisque puisque aujourd'hui
monsieur le sénateur nous vaccinons
davantage que l'espagne que l'italie qui
est près de votre de votre mais
également mais également mais également
de l'allemagne mais également de
l'allemagne pays auquel nous aimons bien
nous aimons bien
nous vacciner ce sont près de 2 millions
de nos concitoyens qui la semaine
dernière ont été vaccinés et nous
atteindrons l'objectif de 10 millions de
nos concitoyens ayant bénéficié d'une
vaccination d'ici à la fin avril avec un
peu de un peu d'avancé d'ailleurs et les
objectifs de 20 millions d'ici mi mai et
30 millions pour la mi juin son sont
aujourd'hui confirmées on peut
aujourd'hui se faire vacciner de
l'officine au stade comme vous l'avez vu
puisqu'un certain nombre de vaccinés
drones ont été ont été ouvertes
vous l'avez raison vous l'avez vous avez
raison de le de le rappeler aux
stratégies vaccinales repose sur une
priorité d'une part pour les personnes
les plus fragiles et par ailleurs pour
les préfets les professionnels de santé
les plus exposés au virus notamment ceux
qui travaillent en ehpad et ce sont
aujourd'hui plus de 60% des personnels
en ehpad qui ont été vaccinés j'en
appelle comme vous à ce que cela
continue de progresser et ce sont plus
de 60% des possibles de santé sur
l'ensemble de territoire qui ont été qui
ont été vaccinées il est effectivement
de la responsabilité de chacun et en
particulier des professionnels de santé
qui sont auprès de nos concitoyens les
plus fragiles de pouvoir accéder à cette
gêne et vaccination afin de pouvoir nous
protéger tous et que nous en sortions le
plus rapidement possible même de masquer
quelques secondes
monsieur le ministre vous ne répondez
pas à la question et je vous avoue ne
pas comprendre votre frilosité mon
interrogation était pourtant claire et
simple au regard de la pandémie
galopante le gouvernement compte-t-il
simplement s'engager pour rendre la
vaccination des soignants obligatoires
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
françoise gatel pour le groupe de
l'union centriste
merci merci monsieur le président
monsieur le garde des sceaux
ils sont apportés d'engueulades dit
régulièrement le président du sénat
aujourd'hui ils sont a porté deux coups
à porter d'injures leurs familles et le
et leurs biens le sont aussi en 2020 on
a recensé 1300 agression d'élus trois
fois plus qu'en 2019
monsieur le garde des sceaux pourtant
après la mort tragique du maire de
signes en 2019
le sénat et l'assemblée de la ja ont
adopté renforcer des mesures
législatives pour protéger les élus le
ministère de la justice adressée au
procureur deux circulaires les invitant
d'une part à recueillir avec attention
les plaintes des élus et leur demandant
de recourir aux sanctions prévues par la
loi
aujourd'hui le ministre de l'intérieur
met à disposition des élus 350 gendarmes
des négociateurs de la gendarmerie pour
aider les élus à gérer les conflits et
gérer la désescalade
donc on pourrait penser et je le crois
monsieur le garde des sceaux que la
volonté est là
toutefois les circulaires circulent je
n'oserais pas penser qu'elle circule
comme des bouteilles à la mer mais
j'aurais vous interrogez monsieur le
ministre nous ne savons pas quels sont
les effets des circulaires que vous avez
fait qu'est que vous avez adressé donc
pourriez vous nous donner le bilan de
ces circulaires et d'autres pas seriez
vous favorable à ce que chaque année on
dresse un bilan des sanctions qui ont
été prises à l'encontre des agresseurs
d'élus de façon à ce que les élus
sachent qu'ils ne restent pas impunis je
vous remercie on vous répondre la parole
ça monsieur le garde des sceaux ministre
de la justice monsieur eric
dupond-moretti la parole monsieur le
président mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs madame la sénatrice françoise
gatel comment le dire toute attaque
quand un élu est une attaque contre la
république parce que ce sont les élus
qui font vivre la république et la
démocratie
alors naturellement et vous avez raison
on ne peut pas se payer de mots vous
avez rappelé la circulaire que j'ai
prises les circulaires que j'ai prise
qui d'ailleurs succédé aux circulaires
prise par ma prédécesseure
elles ont d'ores et déjà porté leurs
fruits en termes de condamnation les
condamnations ont doublé
soixante deux pour cent de ces
condamnations sont des condamnations de
l'emprisonnement et cet emprisonnement a
augmenté de 10%
naturellement ça n'est pas tout car les
circulaires circulent mais elles sont
lus et notamment par les procureurs qui
ont mis en place des partenariats très
serré avec les différents intervenants
et bien sûr les élus territoriaux grâce
notamment à aux personnels embauchés
dans le cadre de la justice de proximité
mise en place par monsieur le premier
ministre qu'il m'a demandé de décliner
dans ses aspects les plus pragmatiques
voilà où nous en sommes c'est
pratiquement d'ailleurs être étendue sur
l'ensemble du territoire national grâce
à un moteur de recherche que est mis en
place qui est un site intranet à
disposition de tous les magistrats
madame la présidente de la délégation
aux collectivités territoriales gérées
sur vos terres vendredi à rennes un
partenariat particulier a été mis en
place
l'un des personnels embauchés dans le
cas de la justice de proximité est
exclusivement dédié à la relation
parquet élus locaux et d'ailleurs le
parquet s'apprête prochainement à signer
une convention avec l'association des
maires de france et la nrf il est
absolument essentiel que nous luttions
contre les violences faites aux élus mon
engagement sur cette question précise
et je vous prie de croire madame la
sénatrice total inébranlable c'est
absolument essentiel que nous protégions
les élus et donc notre république
bon madame bagatelle merci monsieur le
garde des sceaux merci monsieur le
président je pense qu'ici la question
que je portais elle aurait pu être porté
par chacun des élus sur ces mots merci
monsieur le garde des sceaux de votre
action je pense aujourd'hui au maire de
signes comme nous tous mais je pense
aussi au maire de bron près de lyon qui
aujourd'hui doit exercer son mandat sous
protection policière
vous l'avez dit monsieur le garde des
sceaux les agressions contre les élus
sont des agressions contre la république
et ses agressions mines la république et
faisant très attention à ce que cette
peur qui commence à régner chez les élus
ne commence pas à rendre plus éparses
les rangs de l'armée des fantassins de
la république dont nous avons besoin
parce que c'est eux qui la font au
quotidien et la république lors doit
justice aussi la parole et à notre
collègue stéphane sautarel pour le
groupe l'est républicain
le président mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'économie des finances et
de la relance dans le cadre du plan de
sauvegarde d'air france qui a déjà perdu
plus de 7 milliards d'euros en 2020 vous
avez engagé sa recapitalisation par
l'état à hauteur de 4 milliards d'euros
moins d'un an après l'octroi de 7
milliards d'euros de prêts détail de pge
je m'en réjouis car il en va de notre
souveraineté nationale et cela entre
pleinement dans nos trois objectifs de
prise de participation d'états les
entreprises stratégiques pour la
souveraineté nationale celle remplissant
des missions de service public et enfin
les entreprises en difficultés
systémiques mais disposant encore d'un
modèle valide entre qu'à une section
petter cette crise nous rend tous
modeste et pragmatique mais aussi
volontariste pour reconstruire un
souverainisme industriels que nous avons
trop longtemps abandonnés
je me réjouis aussi les contreparties
sociales qui ont été par ailleurs prévu
en résonance avec le pacte ainsi que les
contreparties en termes de perte de ce
lot à orly qui ont été ramenés de 18 à
22 24 à 18 sans pouvoir bénéficier aux
low cost vous l'avez rappelé le contexte
exige cette politique industrielle
volontariste de l'état
c'est vrai pour nos entreprises
publiques c'est aussi vrai pour nos
entreprises privées et en particulier
les pays et les pme c'est pourquoi ma
question porte sur le rendez-vous majeur
que nous allons avoir avec nos
entreprises en sortie de crise elle
s'inscrit aussi au carrefour de la
mobilisation de l'épargné des français
estimé à 165 milliards d'euros à fin
2021 de l'accroissement de la dette des
entreprises et donc des contraintes que
connaissent les banques depuis bâle 2
nous devons en effet préserver la
capacité d'investissement des
entreprises
pour cela nous devons pouvoir comme vous
le faites fort air france transformer
des pg e en fonds propres ou en
subventions pour les plus petites
entreprises
les fonds propres constitue la vraie
richesse de notre économie en 2020 nous
avons détruit 50 milliards sur
l'ensemble notre système productif
il nous faut impérieusement réalimenter
notre appareil productif et concrétiser
notre ambition
quelle réponse monsieur le ministre
pensez vous apporter à nos entreprises
pour permettre leur investissement d'une
part et l'émergence d'un nouveau
capitalisme populaire et de fond ce
citoyen garanti d'autre part je vous
remercie monsieur lui dise de l'économie
des finances et de la relance de la
parole
oui mais le sénateur je partage votre
analyse sur la nécessité d'apporter un
soutien clair de long terme à nos
entreprises en particulier deux
entreprises industrielles il y à toutes
les entreprises qui ont été les plus
touchés par la crise qu'elles soient pme
petite entreprise ou entreprises de
taille intermédiaire qui sont dans le
secteur de la restauration du tourisme
de l'événementiel du sport la culture
ces entreprises doivent savoir que nous
continuerons à les soutenir
aussi longtemps que cela sera nécessaire
et rien ne serait pire que de retirer
brutalement à ces entreprises des aides
qui leur ont permis de garder la tête au
dessus de l'eau pendant les mois de
crise que nous avons connue et que nous
continuerons de connaître les
entreprises qui sont le plus touchés
peuvent être les plus soutenus elles
doivent pouvoir continuer à bénéficier
de notre soutien ce sera le cas
d'autres entreprises ont déjà commencé à
retrouver des couleurs et veulent
investir mais elle manque de trésorerie
elles ont besoin de transformer leurs
prêts en prêt participatif c'est à dire
des quasi fonds propres qui leur
permettent d'ouvrir de nouvelles lignes
de production d'investir
c'est l'objet des prêts participatifs 20
milliards d'euros est mis à disposition
de ces entreprises pour qu'elles
puissent investir innover ouvrir de
nouvelles lignes de production embaucher
à nouveau sur les territoires et ouvrir
des perspectives
et puis un dernier volet qui est
absolument crucial où vous l'avez
indiqué c'est tiré leçon de cette crise
il ya une leçon à tirer parmi d'autres
c'est que les chaînes de valeur de la
mondialisation telle qu'elle existe
aujourd'hui nous rendent trop vulnérable
à l'égard de d'approvisionnement venues
de l'étranger sur des biens critiques
qui viennent des états unis qu'ils
viennent de l'asie qu'ils viennent de la
chine
on peut pas se permettre de dépendre de
l'asie à près de 100% pour des semi
conducteurs qui servent ensuite de notre
industrie automobile ne veut pas
dépendre des batteries électriques
chinoises ou sud coréenne alors que nous
voulons être indépendant donc nous
allons
c'est une indépendance industriels sur
des chaînes de valeur stratégique sur
les batteries électriques sur le cloud
sur l'intelligence artificielle sur les
semi-conducteurs sur l'hydrogène sur
toutes ces filières de production
industrielle la france veut et va
retrouver son indépendance industriels à
paroles et victor notre collègue émilie
impôts myrhol pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicaine
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre mes chers collègues
monsieur le ministre le 21 février 2018
la cour européenne de justice a rendu un
arrêt 10 arrêts mazdak selon lequel le
temps d'un kyste rentes d'un
sapeur-pompier volontaire doit être
considérée comme une temps de travail au
sens de la directive européenne de 2003
pourtant la loi française du 20 juillet
2011 art avons connu la spécificité du
volontariat qu'elle définit comme un
engagement citoyen libre et qu' il ne
saurait être assimilée à une charge de
travail
la transposition et l'application de ces
tarés inquiète beaucoup non seulement
les sapeurs pompiers mais aussi les élus
qu'ils soient locaux ou parlementaire
cette transposition engendre un effet
impossible la conciliation d'un
engagement volontaire et d'une activité
professionnelle
elle pourrait ainsi porter gravement
atteinte à notre modèle de sécurité
civile fait de la complémentarité
professionnels volontaires et dans la
force est unanimement reconnue or de
façon unilatérale et sans concertation
vous avez initié en novembre
il ne manque près les directeurs de ce
disque qui laisserait penser que la
france pourrait se diriger vers la
simulation des volontaires à des
travailleurs et ce de façon abusive et
infondées vos deux prédécesseurs
monsieur collomb au congrès national des
sapeurs pompiers d'ajaccio et monsieur
castaner devant le parlement avait
affirmé la volonté du gouvernement de
pérenniser et renforcer le volontariat
dont nous connaissons l'importance
fondamentale sur nos territoires
pouvez vous monsieur le ministre nous
précisez vos intentions
pour vous répondre la parole est à mme
marlène schiappa ministre délégué en
charge de la citoyenneté la parole merci
monsieur le président mesdames les
sénatrices mais sur les sénateurs madame
la sénatrice finir hall vous avez
résoudre le rappeler la décision de la
cour de justice de l'union européenne a
jugé que les sapeurs pompiers
volontaires belge devait être en raison
des circonstances d'emploi
contraignantes qui leur sont propres
considérés comme des travailleurs au
sens de la dtt et vous avez parfaitement
raison de le rappeler c'est vrai cette
décision elle a suscité des inquiétudes
dans les dix est également parmi un
certain nombre d'élus je voudrais dire
que les échanges dont le gouvernement
français a pris l'initiative avec la
commission européenne ont permis de nous
confirmer de façon formelle que cet
arrêt n'implique aucunement que les
200000 sapeurs pompiers volontaires
français soit qualifié de travailleurs
le gouvernement et comme vous madame la
sénatrice pleinement attachés au statut
particulier et au modèle de volontariat
français chaque cas d'espèce doit être
examinée en fonction de ses
caractéristiques propres et cette
décision à une remet pas en cause notre
modèle du volontariat
toutefois c'est vrai ce modèle il nous
semble qu'il doit être sécurisée qui
nous faut traiter des situations locales
qui probablement minoritaires pourrait
risquer de fragiliser ce modèle devant
les juridictions
donc je vais vous dire très simplement
que le ministère de l'intérieur n'a
naturellement aucune volonté de
transposer la dtt aux sapeurs pompiers
volontaires dont je voudrais saluer
l'engagement particulièrement cette
période de pandémie et qu'il ne saurait
être question pour nous de rester sans
agir pour traiter les fragilités
juridiques qui peuvent exister sur ce
dossier qui est sensible mais
structurant pour le modèle français de
la sécurité civile
le gouvernement veut privilégier la
concertation vous l'avez rappelé voilà
comment nous avons procédé nous avons
demandé au préfet aux directeurs
généraux de la sécurité civile et de la
gestion des crises de lancer cette large
concertation sur les nécessaires
adaptations au modèle actuel de
volontariat les messages du gouvernement
dont vous faites mention madame la
sénatrice avait pour but de préparer
justement cette concertation
elle est menée en liaison étroite avec
les disent intéressés
au premier chef et avec l'ensemble du
réseau de leurs partenaires les acteurs
de la sécurité civile les élus il est
évident que l'ensemble des besoins
opérationnels doivent être analysées et
les réponses elles seront adaptées tant
au quotidien des sapeurs pompiers
volontaires et cisco crise
exceptionnelle comme celle que nous
connaissons à l'heure actuelle je vous
remercie
merci voilà pour myrhol ministre vous
n'avez guère dissipé nos inquiétudes
le volontariat vous l'avez rappelé est
une activité altruiste et généreuse au
bénéfice de nos populations et qui ne
saurait être considéré en aucun cas
quand même travail mais comme un
engagement citoyen fort en fait ce n'est
pas une étude de quelques cas spéciaux
que nous demandons est que l'ensemble
des papiers sapeurs pompiers de france
attend de vous l'ensemble des sapeurs
pompiers à temps de vous l'écriture
d'une nouvelle directive spécifique et
non une scène de dérogation au cas par
cas
la france va présider dans quelques mois
en janvier prochain l'union européenne
voilà une belle occasion de conclure ce
dossier collègue martin berthet pour le
groupe l'est républicain
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'économie des
finances et de la relance monsieur le
ministre
de plus en plus nombreuses sont les
entreprises être extrêmement inquiète
face aux difficultés que leur pose la
flambée des prix des matières premières
cela concerne l'acier le cuivre le
minerai de fer le zinc le vert mais
aussi dans des proportions très
importantes le bois aucune matière
première n'était pas renié le cuivre
augmenté de 28% depuis un an le 5 2 22
la livraison de bois était qu est devenu
extrêmement difficile les matériaux
deviennent très rare et très cher
le phénomène s'est répandue au niveau
mondial comme une traînée de poudre la
tension devrait perdurer encore
plusieurs mois face à ces hausses
brutales
il existe un véritable danger pour les
entreprises qui se sont engagées sur des
bases devenu obsolète
bien sûr monsieur le ministre si les
prix des matières premières vous échappe
ses entreprises méritent toute votre
attention c'est dès à présent qu'il vous
faut activer des leviers pour agir face
à cette situation exceptionnelle ne
pensez vous pas que les règles
strictes qui encadrent qui encadre la
commande publique pourrait être que
temporairement assouplies ne faut-il pas
réfléchir pendant cette période si
particulière à une possibilité pour le
maître d'ouvragé publics de façon
systématique de revoir les conditions
initiales du contrat qu'il s'agisse du
prix ou des délais d'exécution
ne faudrait-il afin que nos entreprises
passent ce nouveau cap
un style et de la souplesse en
permettant plus aisément et plus
rapidement
l'application des clauses de révision de
prix même lorsque les marchés ont été
signés à prix ferme non actualisable ni
révisable en outre face au risque de
blocage des 100 des chantiers dans les
semaines à venir
il convient de réactiver les ordonnances
qui au printemps 2020 avec
transitoirement gelé les pénalités de
retard des marchés publics et privés
pour vous répondre la parole tommy 10 de
l'économie des finances et de la relance
c'est le maire de la parole oui mais la
sénatrice merci pour vos propositions
que je trouve pertinente donc je vous
propose que nous les étudions ensemble
notamment sur les règles de la commande
publique sur les pénalités en cas de
retard ou de mauvaise exécution je pense
qu'il ya des choses qui les mérite
d'être étudiée très attentivement pour
soutenir les entreprises dans votre
département de la savoie comme ailleurs
de manière plus générale il ya
effectivement une flambée du cours des
matières premières
elle s'explique très simplement
l'économie mondiale est en train de
redémarrer
elle redémarre très fort en chine et en
asie
elle redémarre également aux états unis
sous l'impulsion du plan de relance
lancé par le président biden je souhaite
également que l'union européenne ne soit
pas à la traîne puisque plus rapidement
possible mettre en oeuvre son plan de
relance de façon à ce qu'elle renoue
avec la croissance et qu'elle reste dans
la course économique mondial aux côtés
de la chine est aux côtés des états unis
je souhaite également qu'on réfléchisse
de manière plus stratégique à notre
indépendance sur un certain nombre de
matériaux prenez l'acier j'ai toujours
considéré qu'il y avait
un avenir pour les aciéries pour la
métallurgie en france et en europe et
qu'il n'y avait aucune raison que nous
abandonnions les industries de l'acier
ou de la métallurgie lourdes en france
et en europe
je me suis battue pour sauver as koval
hayange et un certain nombre
d'entreprises industrielles c'est que je
crois profondément qu'il ya un avenir
pour l'acier et les métallurgie dans
notre pays mais il ya une condition
c'est nous orienter vers une industrie
décarbonés s'est accélérée la
décarbonation de ces entreprises c'est
ce que nous avons fait par exemple à
fos-sur-mer en investissant récemment
sur le site d'arcelormittal plus de 60
millions d'euros pour décarbonés ce site
et qu'en contrepartie de cela parce que
nous faisons de l'acier propres nous
taxons l'acier salle qui vient d'asie où
d'autres pays et qui ne respectent pas
les mêmes règles environnementales parce
qu'on ne peut pas demander à nos
industriels de fer de l'acier décarbonés
qui est plus coûteux tout en rien
portant sans taxes et sans taxe carbone
aux frontières en acier qui lui n'est
pas produit dans les mêmes conditions
environnementales
voilà l'avenir de l'industrie française
décarbonés avec une protection aux
frontières qui s'appelle la taxe carbone
aux frontières
madame berthet quelques secondes merci
beaucoup monsieur mise pour vos
propositions il y a effectivement
urgence à agir pour que la situation de
nos entreprises ne s'aggrave pas et il y
à aussi en jeu
les équipes au chômage partiel cet
automne faute de matériaux pour réaliser
les chantiers
merci la parole est maintenant notre
collègue florence lassarade pour le
groupe l'est républicain
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
ma question s'adresse au ministre des
transports et porte sur la suppression
totale de la navette aérienne entre
bordeaux et orly que vous venez de
confirmer cette décision fondée
uniquement sur des considérations
environnementales est actée par le
projet de loi climat sans qu'aucune
concertation avec les élus locaux net eu
lieu en amont pourtant cette navette
aérienne transport jusqu'à 550 mille
passagers par an la métropole bordelaise
constitue par ailleurs le troisième
bassin d'emploi pour l'aéronautique en
france et représente près de 35 mille
salariés avec 300 entreprises dont
dassault thales alors que la région est
déjà fortement impacté par la crise
cette suppression de risque
cette suppression risque de remettre en
question le choix de localisation et de
développement de nombreuses entreprises
par ailleurs dans son avis sur le projet
de lutte contre le dérèglement
climatique et renforcement de la
résilience face à ces effets le conseil
d'état critique la suppression de la
navette à france entre bordeaux et orly
ils soulignent que les conséquences
économiques et concurrentiels de
l'interdiction sont trop succinctement
abordés il reproche aussi de ne pas
avoir pris en compte le principe de
liberté des transports aériens qui
prévaut dans l'union européenne
de surcroît j'attire votre attention sur
le fait que l'aéroport de bordeaux s'est
doté d'un plan d'orientation stratégie
volontariste en termes de lutte contre
les nuisances sonores et visant à la
neutralité carbone informe de devenir un
équipement éco responsable la fille
aéronautique travaille ardemment la
fabrication d'avions moins polluants
dans le cadre du programme européen
clean sky
monsieur le ministre plutôt qu'une
suppression totale dont de cette liaison
aérienne ne serait-il pas possible
d'organiser une transition acceptable en
mettant maintenant au minimum deux
allers-retours quotidiens pourrait
prendre la parole et au but
chargé les transports monsieur djebbari
vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice vous interrogez madame la
sénatrice le gouvernement sur l'arrêt de
la ligne entre paris ici voilà pardon
entre paris et paris orly et et bordeaux
conséquence de l'article 36 actuellement
débattu à l'assemblée nationale dans le
cadre du projet de loi climat et
résidences cet article vous avez fait
référence préfèrent le train à l'avion
dès lors qu'une alternative ferroviaire
robuste souvent en tgv existe en moins
de 2h30 nous organisons madame la
sénatrice est cette transition
d'abord nous accompagnons et cela a été
dit à de nombreuses reprises aujourd'hui
le secteur aérien dans sa transition
écologique et énergétique et nous y
investissons en démontant tout à fait
considérable nous avons évidemment à
coeur de maintenir l'attractivité des
territoires et les allers-retours
journées professionnelles seront
évidemment toujours possible ces
restrictions ne concerneront pas les
vols à haut niveau de correspondance
raison pour laquelle les liaisons vers
roissy charles de gaulle seront
maintenus et la continuité va les
outre-mer de la même façon sera assurée
enfin ces lignes concernées bénéficient
toutes d'une liaison ferroviaire de
qualité et d aménagement de fréquences à
la hausse dès que la crise sanitaire
s'éloignera de nous il nous permettra de
retrouver un niveau de desserte
habituelle sur bordeaux en particulier
j'ai demandé à madame la préfète de
région de d'être particulièrement
attentive aux besoins locaux notamment
en termes d'accessibilité et de
dessertes régionales et les modalités
précises de l'application de cet article
seront évidemment définies par décret je
souhaite que les élus soient étroitement
associés
je vous remercie madame le sahara
le sujet monsieur le ministre c'est pas
le train je vous invite à venir à
bordeaux pour voir comme c'est pratique
de venir prendre le train en centre
ville
quand on habite en région nouvelle
aquitaine ou même en périphérie de
bordeaux
donc s'il faut effectivement une heure
et demie de voiture pour reprendre le
train c'est un problème
le sujet c'est que le secteur aérien ne
devrait pas être le bouc émissaire de la
pollution en privons bordeaux et sa
région d'un atout essentiel
d'attractivité
l'enjeu ce sont ces 35 mille emplois de
la filière aéronautique c'est ça la
question et vous n'arrivez pas senti le
le vrai sens de la question il me semble
c'est le premier ministre faisait
messieurs les ministres merci je vous
rappelle que nos prochaines questions
d'actualité auront lieu le 14 avril à
15h la science est suspendu et sera
reprise à 16h30 pour les conclusions de
la commission mixte paritaire sur la
proposition de loi pour une sécurité
globale préservant les libertés la
séance est suspendue
voilà pour cette séance de questions
d'actualité au gouvernement que vous
avez pu suivre en direct et en
intégralité sur public sénat tout de
suite c'est le débriefer on va
d'ailleurs allé voir steve jourdain dans
l'hémicycle du sénat steve il ya eu cet
après midi beaucoup de questions sur le
secteur aéronautique notamment air
france mais aussi sur le bug de l'école
à distance bug hier qui a provoqué pas
mal de difficultés pour les enseignants
les parents les enfants pour tout le
monde
école à distance épisode 2 en quelque
sorte
tam petit rappel 1 depuis hier les
établissements scolaires sont fermés en
france enseignement à distance est la
norme l'enseignement à distance c'est la
règle le problème est bien c'est que
tout ne s'est pas vraiment passé comme
prévu
hier de nombreux bugs informatiques ont
perturbé les cours et continue
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui est bien de
perturber ses cours du coup et bien les
sénateurs voulaient savoir ce qu'il se
passe vous voulez savoir ce qui ne
fonctionne pas et le sénateur et l'air
ronan le gleut n'a pas vraiment vraiment
ménagé le gouvernement a coûté le
vous aviez un an pour vous préparer un
an de préparation la réalité c'est tout
simplement monsieur le ministre que vous
n'étiez pas prêts et donc ma question
elle est la suivante comment vous la
prétendue start up née shon portée en
étendard par emmanuel macron peut
justifier un tel fiasco
réponse du gouvernement réponse de
jean-michel blanquer r les
dysfonctionnements ne sont pas de la
responsabilité de l'exécutif la faute ne
revient pas au gouvernement écouter
deuxième assertion de votre part le fait
que nous ne serions pas prêt là aussi
c'est une insulte aux enseignants qui
étaient tous très fière et je l' ai dit
tout à l'heure aux sénateurs la faune il
était près ce qui n'a pas marché c'est
en effet les tuyaux comme on dit ces
tuyaux
alors je vous le répète très clairement
ne sont pas de la compétence de
l'éducation nationale cela relève des
régions et des départements
donc en effet la semaine dernière les
collectivités locales nous ont dit
qu'elles étaient prêtes
certaines l'était et d'ailleurs
l'enseignement à distance s'est bien
passé pour une bonne partie du pays hier
sur toute une série de régions ça n'a
pas été le cas
c'est en train d'être réparé
actuellement et j'ai bonne confiance
pour le que le saas rétablisse aussi
bien aujourd'hui comme nous constatons
déjà que demain et après demain donc de
grâce ne faisons pas de polémiques
inutiles
parlons de façon informé du sujet et oui
l'éducation nationale a énormément
travaillé sur ces sujets depuis un an et
ne se sont pas injuriés personnes qui
ont travaillé dans ce sens autre thème
très fort de cette séance d'actualité
l'avenir du secteur aérien en france on
a appris et bien lundi que le groupe air
france allait bien être recapitalisées
par l'état ça c'est à la suite du feu
vert donné par bruxelles au plan proposé
par le gouvernement un plan qui suscite
énormément de questions parmi les
sénateurs de gauche écouter
quelle stratégie pour la décarbonation
du secteur il y a les progrès techniques
mais aussi les reports quand c'est
possible vers d'autres modes de
transport moins émetteur est il viable
de s'en remettre à l'initiative privée
les acteurs du secteur ne faut-il pas
envisager des changements structurels
monsieur le ministre quel
conditionnalité climatique quels
conditionnalité sociale pour ces aides
côté gouvernement on assure que les
emplois seront bien préservés bruno leur
maire promet même que le gouvernement
fera tout pour faire d'air france une
compagnie plus verte et même la
compagnie aérienne la plus verte du
monde écoutez le je me permettais je
vous dirais que vous ne manquez pas
d'air quant au reproche tout vous nous
fait d'avoir attaqué collectivement la
maire de poitiers vous me permettrait de
confirmer que je ne souhaite pas et que
personne ici de souhaite que les
responsables politiques s'occupent des
rêves de nos enfants nous continuerons à
soutenir massivement et durablement le
transport aérien les pme qui travaillent
dans l'aérien le secteur aéronautique
airbus
toute l'industrie française qui fait
notre excellent sur le transport aérien
et nous allons le faire avec cette
ambition qui est d'accélérer la
décarbonation notre industrie parce que
oui nous pouvons être la première nation
est le premier continent au monde à
proposer un avion zéro carbone
fonctionnant à hydrogène
c'est ça notre ambition plutôt que de
laisser des avions et les emplois avec
cloués au sol voilà et à gauche on
promet que le dossier les pinèdes aussi
des emplois dans le secteur aérien sera
scruté de très près tam
merci merci beaucoup stif pour toutes
ces explications et tout de suite on va
rejoindre alexandre poussard alexandre
qui est justement avec le sénateur
écologiste
jacques fernique qu'on a entendu à
l'instant dans l'hémicycle pour parler
et bien de la stratégie décarbonation du
secteur aéronautique et puis aussi
réagir à ce petit tacle à la maire de
poitiers qui a eu tout à l'heure bruno
le maire dans l'hémicycle la maire de
poitiers qui ne veut plus subventionner
les aéro club alexandre oui
effectivement d'abord jacques fernique
une réaction encore ce petit tacle de la
part du gouvernement
après les propos de la maire de poitiers
qui ne voulait plus subventionnés enfin
qui a diminué sa subvention pour les
aéro clubs locaux et qui a parlé des
rêves d'enfants et de l'avion c'est
encore le gouvernement qui rentre dans
la polémique en bas je veux dire bruno
le maire n'a pas résisté à l'envi de
remettre une pièce dans la machine à
caricaturer les écolos alors que sur le
fond de la faire il s'agit de 4000 euros
en plus ou en moins à la subvention de
l'aéro club du poitou moi ma question
elle portait sur les vraies exigences
des salariés de l'aéronautique
ces quatre cent mille emplois pour le
maintien la sauvegarde de l'emploi pour
les reconversions qui seront nécessaires
dans le cadre de la transition des
évolutions de l'aéronautique mon
exigence aussi citer qu il réponde sur
ce que demande le haut conseil pour le
climat il faut que l'aérien dès
maintenant baisse chaque année de quatre
et demi pour cent par an ses émissions
de carbone c'est important c'est ce qui
permettra aussi l'excellence économique
dans notre pays
et pourtant il a dit que l'objectif de
l'europe c'était d'avoir le premier
avion à zéro carbone avion à hydrogène
très bien super ça me rassure mais ce
qui me rassurerait d'autant plus si on
si on a une véritable politique non pas
de deux réalisations exceptionnelles
mais de massification du changement
c'est ça qu'il faut engager et c'est
pour ça que les vraies questions
structurelles parce qu'aujourd'hui ce
sont des acteurs privés on a le monde de
l'aéronautique c'est essentiellement
l'initiative privée qui a la main il est
temps que l'état se pose la question de
reprendre la main sérieusement parce que
les aides publiques sont considérables
ces 4 milliard 4 milliards d'argent
public que payent les contribuables il
faut des conditionnalités sociale
écologique exigeante justement sur le
niveau social et sur le plan de
sauvetage d'air france avec l'état qui
va devenir le premier actionnaire d'air
france
il ya quand même ce plan de suppressions
de postes qui a été annoncé il ya
quelques mois
est-ce que bruno le maire vous a rassuré
sur les garanties autour de ces
événements
même mon collègue communiste est revenu
quelques instants après sur la question
et sa réponse bruno le maire n'a pas
so lu ment pas parler de ses 7500 qui
sont déjà programmées suppressions
d'emplois à air france et d'humilier qui
va s'y rajouter or il est important
là dessus que l'état joue son rôle de
sauvegarde de l'emploi
merci beaucoup et jacques fernique pour
votre réaction et vous le voyez tam les
sénateurs de gauche ne sont toujours pas
rassurés sur le maintien des emplois
chez air france merci merci beaucoup
alexandre danse débriefer bien on va
continuer les nombreuses réactions salle
des conférences et vous allez maintenant
être avec marc fesneau
le ministre chargé des relations avec le
parlement est également futurs candidats
aux régionales dans la région centre val
de loire il est à votre micro alexandre
effectivement on va parler des élections
régionales puisque dans sept jours très
exactement ici au sénat il y aura un
débat avec le gouvernement sur et bien
la tenue de la campagne des élections
départementales et régionales c'est
important de consulter toutes les
formations politiques les parlementaires
pour mener ces organisé organisé cette
campagne
oui le président la république elle
pourrait ministre ont souhaité à l'issue
du rapport qui a été produit par le
comité scientifique le conseil
scientifique qui n'a pas tranché au fond
la question qui a donné un certain
nombre d' attendus pour la campagne est
attendu pour le jour du vote qui puisse
y avoir un débat à l'assemblée nationale
et au sénat à l'assemblée mardi au sénat
mercredi prochain permettant au fond sur
la base du comité scientifique des
recommandations du comité scientifique
que chacun puisse s'exprimer sur la
manière dont il voit la campagne la
manière dont il voit la tenue du bureau
de vote pour kung fu ont trouvé des
voies et moyens du consensus le premier
ministre a rappelé dans sa déclaration
la semaine dernière le postulat de base
c'est que les élections sont prévues les
13 et 20 juin prochains
mais il faut regarder ensemble si nous
partageons bien le diagnostic sur la
manière dont on peut faire campagne et
sur la manière dont pourront être tenues
les bureaux doigt parce qu'il ya un
certain nombre de contraintes qui
peuvent peser sur les candidats quels
qu'ils soient et un certain nombre de
contraintes qui peuvent peser parce que
moi j'y pense comme anciens maires
surtout les élus municipaux surtout les
mères
qui ont déjà l'organisation d'un scrutin
qui en soi nécessite une organisation au
fond il ya deux scrutins en plus ce qui
est assez rare dont dans le schéma
électorale classique
et puis dans des contrats avec des
contraintes sanitaires particulière et
donc c'est bien que l'assemblée
nationale est évidemment le sénat et la
chambre des territoires ils puissent
avoir ce débat est justement sur cette
manière et bien nouvelles de faire
campagne
quelles pourraient être les solutions
est ce que on peut imaginer que les
assesseurs seront vaccinés en priorité
que les électeurs devront être testés 72
heures avant et puis qui est des
dérogations de deux distances en cette
période de confinement pour pouvoir
faire campagne pour les candidats
et ben si c'est toutes ces questions là
qu'ils se posent laquelle il nous
appartient pas à cela de répondre le
opportuniste à solliciter aussi les
groupes politiques et les partis
politiques pour qu'ils fassent état y
compris dans le cadre qui est donné en
espèces de quartier donné par le comité
scientifique et sur cette base là qu'il
faudra qu'on essaie de trouver des voies
de consensus faut pas non plus que les
mesures que nous proposerions vise à
décourager les gens d'aller voter
voyez ce que je veux dire faut quand
même l'objectif de ces élections c'est
que la campagne puisse se faire et que
les électeurs soient mobilisés je crois
que dans démocratie c'est l'essentiel
c'est que les électeurs et puisse se
saisir des sujets départementaux des
sujets régionaux premiers éléments et
deuxièmement qu'ils aient envie de voter
les 13 et 20 juin prochains et donc faut
faire attention à ce que les mesures
tenant compte quand même des
préconisations sanitaire ne viennent pas
découragé massivement les français
d'aller voter parce que sinon nous
aurions un problème démocratique aussi
qui est celui d'une élection où les
résultats seraient auber et d'une
certaine façon par le taux de
participation qui serait trop faible
alors vous personnellement marc fesneau
vous êtes tête de liste de la majorité
présidentielle dans la région centre val
de loire
comment vous faites campagne
concrètement sur le terrain il vous
aurait échappé quelque chose je n'ai pas
déclaré ma candidature je travaille avec
l'équipe
vous avez employé le bon terme le moment
venu pardon de le dire je ne viendrai
pas au palais du luxembourg le dire ce
que j'ai à dire aux habitants de la
région centre val de loire met en tout
cas l'ensemble de des chefs de file
l'ensemble des têtes de liste en tout
cas ceux qui s'intéressent aux campagnes
régionales essayer de regarder comment
au fond
vers les citoyens puisque les citoyens
peuvent au moins être mobile compte tenu
des restrictions
ça nécessite aussi de regarder si ce qui
est acceptable ou pas en termes de
tractage en termes de boîtes âge il faut
qu'on essaie d'inventer d'autres formes
de campagne je crois pas qu'on règle
toute la question en disant il suffit
d'aller sur les réseaux sociaux une
campagne électorale c'est une campagne
de contact comme même si nous sommes à
distance réglementaire si je peux dire
et avec un masque au moins on se voit on
se parle il ya quelque chose qui est
autre chose que la virtualité des
échanges sur les grands réseaux sociaux
que nous connaissons donc il faut sans
doute des moyens dématérialisée mais ça
peut pas résumer la campagne et donc il
faut je vois beaucoup de candidats qui
essaie de trouver des solutions qui avec
des modes itinérant avec des voitures ou
des permanences mobile qui avec des
formes de meetings dématérialisée enfin
bon il ya un certain nombre de choses
qui sont à l'heure j'imagine que les
ensembles des candidats font preuve
d'ingéniosité je crois que c'est
l'intérêt tout le monde pour qu'au moins
les électeurs s'intéressent à la
question puisque la campagne c'est aussi
du contact merci beaucoup marché d'avoir
répondu à merci beaucoup merci merci
beaucoup alexandre pour cette nouvelle
interview cette nouvelle réaction
alors que je vous le rappelle la semaine
prochaine se tiendra au sénat mercredi
prochain un débat en vertu de l'article
50-1 autour de la tenue des élections
régionales
toujours sur ce thème alexandre vous
êtes d'ailleurs avec l'ancien président
de la commission des lois aujourd'hui
questeur du sénat philippe bas mais oui
philippe bas comment vous l'imaginez
cette campagne électorale pas comme les
autres pour les prochaines élections
régionales et départementales est ce
qu'elle est ce qu'elle va être vraiment
possible sur le terrain
on le sait bien que la campagne ne va
pas pouvoir se dérouler comme d'habitude
nous avions d'ailleurs ici proposé que
la france télévisions face des clips de
campagne comme pour les élections
législatives
ça change pas la face du monde mais au
moins que tout ce qui est en notre
pouvoir on le fasse malheureusement la
majorité l'a refusée il va falloir
innover
je crois qu'il va falloir être beaucoup
plus présents sur les réseaux sociaux
puis il faut que je vous les médias vous
assuriez comme vous le faites
notre fonction d'informations pour que
les électeurs sachent qui a des
régionales et que c'est très important
les régionales parce que comme les
départementales d'ailleurs c'est la vie
quotidienne et les territoires ils ont
montré pendant la crise du que vides
leur réactivité leur capacité de
répondre concrètement aux problèmes des
français alors que parfois la très
lourde mécanique de la bureaucratie
d'état tardait à apporter des solutions
aux problèmes que nous avons rencontrés
alors il ya un enjeu médiatique a
également un enjeu sanitaire
quelles conditions faut-il mettre en
oeuvre pour réussir au niveau sanitaire
ce scrutin est cette campagne et nous en
avons délibéré avec françois noël buffet
ce matin en commission des lois
ça sujet important pour nous pour nous
sur lequel nous avons travaillé depuis
un an sommes tous des grands traumatisés
du premier tour des municipales la
veille premiers ministres edouard
philippe annonce la fermeture des
restaurants et des bas et le lendemain
il fait le confinement entre les deux
premiers tours des municipales c'était
dans l'oeil du cyclone c'est-à-dire un
moment vraiment terrible bon mais
ensuite les élections de juin
eh bien on a eu le temps de les préparer
et elles se sont déroulées dans de
bonnes conditions sanitaires
avec pour les bureaux de vote toutes les
précautions utiles c'est pas plus
compliqué que d'aller au supermarché
quant à la campagne qui va précéder
vous savez des conditions modernes d'une
campagne emmanuel macron en sait quelque
chose elle elle n'implique pas
nécessairement un grand déferlement de
distribution de tracts sur les marchés
mais qui reste autorisée dans le temps
que les marchés sont là on a le droit
d'aller sur les marchés
on peut frapper à la porte des maisons
et tout le monde je le répète est à
égalité dans devant les conditions de
cette campagne électorale locaux vides
ne privilégie personne il ne privilégie
aucun candidat
donc ils seront tous à égalité partout
dans le monde
on sait comment organiser des élections
on l'a vu aux états unis on l'a vu au
portugal pour des élections
présidentielles mais il ya des élections
locales et nationales partout en europe
vous avec la france se singularise en
mettant entre parenthèses sa vie
démocratique au moment où on en a le
plus besoin
parce qu'il faut préserver nos libertés
il faut agir concrètement et donner à
des élus de terrain
le pouvoir d'agir alors sur ces
élections le gouvernement organise une
concertation des différentes formations
politiques également des parlementaires
il y aura un débat la semaine prochaine
au sénat sur justement les manières de
bien organiser cette campagne c'est une
manière pour le gouvernement de partager
la responsabilité
nous avons voté on va pas toutes les
trois semaines redire oui faut faire des
élections en juin
ces élections en jeu assez des élections
qui ont déjà été reportés elle devait
avoir lieu en mars
on va pas les reporter
indéfiniment la démocratie il ya des
échéances il faut les respecter sauf cas
de force majeure aujourd'hui personne ne
peut dire que il sera impossible de
faire campagne
fin mai et début juin et qui sera
impossible de tenir des bureaux de vote
à cette date le gouvernement fait ce
qu'il veut il semble bien aimé faire des
débats on refuse pas le débat ouais
c'est un peu singulier comme méthode
alors qu'on vient de voter une loi merci
beaucoup je suis dans ma vie pour votre
réaction
merci merci beaucoup alexandre on
continue ce débris fait tout de suite on
va rejoindre jean notre streamer
politique jean massiet sur twitch alors
jean bacquet ce que les internautes ont
pensé de cette séance tout simplement
qu'est ce qu'ils en ont retenu et bien
écoute ta mais ils en ont retenu
notamment les questionnements vis-à-vis
du gouvernement sur l'avenir du
transport aérien figure toi que ça
soulève des débats des questionnements
assez intéressant et compris chez les
internautes
on a vu la passe d'armes entre bruno le
maire et de sénateur écolo jacques
fernique sénateur écolo évidemment qui
prenait la parole suite à la polémique
tu t'en souviens à la mairie de poitiers
et bien figure toi que sur ce débat là
les internautes eux aussi sont divisés
tout le monde n'est pas tout à fait
d'accord sur le sujet entre ceux qui
pensent qu'il faut apporter une aide
nécessaire à un secteur économique tout
entier notamment pour les personnes qui
bossent dans les usines du secteur
aérien et de la compagnie aérienne
nationale
et puis les autres qui pensent que les
écolos aussi raison de tirer la sonnette
d'alarmé sur l'avenir du secteur et de
ça et finalement de sa place dans un
monde en transition écologique donc tu
vois que voilà c'était assez intéressant
de voir que au sénat comme sur internet
il ya des débats assez intéressant sur
ces sujets lorsqu'ils sont soulevées
pendant les séances et l'autre l'autre
sujet évidemment qu'on a vu c'est la
question des bugs
à l'école on était quand même en train
d'en parler avec le chat la juste avant
les bugs à l'école là aussi les
internautes se sont sont pas très
satisfaits des réponses de jean michel
blanquer on a vu un jean michel blanquer
est d'ailleurs assez énervé assez en
colère sur la question qui lui était
posée notamment par ronan le gleut le
sénateur qui a mis le doigt là où ça
fait mal la préparation du du ministre
de l'éducation nationale est là aussi se
pose des questions assez intéressante
jean michel blanquer requis se
dédouanant parti en disant que coûte et
ce n'est pas l'éducation nationale nous
notre côté on était prêts c'est à cause
des régions c'est elle qui s'occupe des
tuyaux comme il a dit baala figure toi
voilà là aussi un débat sur sur le tchat
il y en a qui se pose la question de
savoir est ce qu il a raison jean michel
blanquer est ce que les profs d'ailleurs
était vraiment près autant que ça j'en
ai vu de 3 dans chat
qui était pas vraiment aussi catégorique
que jean michel blanquer
mais donc donc voilà qu'en est il de la
responsabilité exacte des systèmes
numériques à l'école est ce que c'est
vraiment les conseils régionaux les
collectivités locales
est-ce que c'est l'éducation nationale
est ce que les torts sont partagés le
débat continue d'être vifs
voilà pour cette séance aujourd'hui
table merci merci beaucoup aux gens et
je rappelle t-on invité sur twitch tout
à l'heure c'est la sénatrice et l'ère
des bouches du rhône valérie boyer que
tu vas avoir à partir de 17h à la
semaine prochaine jean merci beaucoup et
j'en parlais à l'instant effectivement
il ya eu plusieurs échanges dans
l'hémicycle au tour est bien de ce bug
qui a frappé l'école à distance
hier et jean michel blanquer a dû
répondre à deux reprises à des questions
écoutez bien tout à l'heure sa réponse à
laurent lafon le président de la
commission de la culture et de
l'éducation on écoute jean michel
blanquer et puis laurent lafon va réagir
ensuite au micro d'alexandre depuis un
an il s'est passé beaucoup de choses il
ya eu préparation importante des
professeurs en particulier la formation
à distance
ils étaient tous très fière et je
regrette d'autant plus les phénomènes
qui se sont passées qui sont des
phénomènes techniques sur le plan
pédagogique des professeurs étaient
prêts que le report sur différents
opérateurs en france fait que on
constate et je le déplore que certains
opérateurs n'ont pas la puissance
technique pour suivre ce n'est pas de la
compétence de l'éducation nationale je
le rappelle et j'observe que certains
qui sont prompts à mettre les
responsabilités sur l'éducation
nationale doivent aujourd'hui surtout
nous expliquer ce qui s'est passé c'est
donc ce que nous saurons dans le détail
tout au long des prochains temps mais
dans l'immédiat
nous travaillons surtout au
rétablissement des choses c'est ce qui
se passe en lien avec les régions et en
lien avec les opérateurs concernés sur
le cned il ya eu des cyberattaques j'y
répondrai peut-être encore tout à
l'heure et essayer nous avons d'ailleurs
déposé plainte pour ces cyber-attaques
probablement certaines depuis l'hexagone
d'autres depuis l'étranger mais c'est si
tu es belle attaque ont été extrêmement
importante au moment même où des
centaines de milliers de comptes étaient
par ailleurs créé pour faire face à la
situation alors laurent lafon at il été
satisfait par la réponse du ministre de
l'éducation nationale qui a notamment
parlé de nombreuses cyber attaques hier
eh bien on va le voir avec alexandre
pousse à vous êtes avec le sait
naters union centriste laurent lafon oui
laurent lafon qu'est ce que vous avez
pensé de ces réponses du ministre de
l'éducation nationale par rapport à tout
c'est tout c'est pas dans tous ces
problèmes de connexion à hier dans
l'école à la maison
manifestement le ministre n'est pas très
à l'aise et du coup il n'est pas très
convaincant quand on les écoute sur sur
ces questions au skate 2 frappant c'est
que ça fait maintenant des mois que
l'hypothèse d'un rebond finement et est
envisagé et donc quand on se retrouve
comme ça dans une situation d'un
préparation c'est étonnant et le
ministre a rejeté la responsabilité sur
les tuyaux si je comprends bien sûr tous
ceux qui acheminent l'information
c'était de la responsabilité du
ministère de prévenir toutes les
personnes qui seraient concernées par
cet afflux massif sur les réseaux d'aidé
et des étudiants manifestaient des
élèves par des bandes justement sanaa ça
n'a pas été fait je regrette très
franchement qu'il n'est pas assumer
davantage la part de responsabilité du
ministère oui le ministre de l'éducation
qui rejette également la responsabilité
sur les régions responsables de ces
environnements numériques de travail
il ya une réponse politique en pointant
la faute des régions je ne sais pas mais
je lui ai posé la question quelles
informations ils avaient donné aux
régions une appareil podium cet aspect
s'arrêter intéressant qui nous disent
quand est-ce qu'il a prévenu les régions
de la mise en place de deux durs
confinement vous pour kilea qu'elle
prenne les mesures nécessaires est ce
qu'il ya eu des discussions qui ont eu
lieu avec elles manifestement nos jeunes
je pense que c'est un une fausse réponse
qu'il a apporté en pointant du doigt les
les
les régions j'espère qu'il n'y avait pas
d'arrière-pensées politiques alors sur
les cyberattaques qui ont concerné et
bien le cned à l'éducation à domicile
est ce que jean michel blanquer a
vraiment tiré les leçons ce qu'il y
avait eu des tirs et des cyber-attaques
a au moment du premier confinement et là
elles se reproduisent
c'est la question que lui demander
effectivement il ya un an il ya eu déjà
des cyberattaques on sait que
malheureusement les cyber attaques sont
une sont une réalité
on sait aussi que quand on annonce que
12 millions de dhs et les français vont
être
vont être instruits à distance on
s'expose à ce type de d'attac donc quels
ont été les mesures préventives prises
quelles ont été les leçons tirées des
cyberattaques de l'année dernière c'est
toutes ces questions qui sont en suspens
et pour lequel le ministre n'a pas
répondu cet après-midi en tout cas le
président la république emmanuel macron
a bien rappelé que la rentrée pour les
écoles primaires en présentiel
c'était fin avril le retour en
présentiel pour les collèges et lycées
début mai est ce qu'il faut pour les
collèges et lycées qu'il y ait une
partie en distance yale quand même pour
moi je suis sanitaires je suis de ceux
qui pensent que la priorité des
priorités c'est le retour à l'école pour
tous que ce soit des enfants de
maternelle élémentaire mais aussi bien
sûr les les collégiens et les lycéens et
j'allais dire que plus on se rapproche
de la fin de l'année plus pour les
lycéens notamment qui ont la perspective
du bac qui se rapproche plus cette
exigence de présence dans les
établissements est importante alors
évidemment il y a les conditions
sanitaires et la propagation du virus
qui s'impose à nous mais tout ce qui
peut être fait pour permettre le retour
des élèves le plus rapidement possible à
l'école est une bonne chose et puis y
aura moins de bugs informatiques du coup
et en plus ça arrive vite les bugs
informatiques ainsi beaucoup laurent
lafon d'avoir répondu à mes questions
merci merci beaucoup alexandre pour
toutes ces réactions salle des
conférences
réaction à chaud après la séance de
questions d'actualité au gouvernement et
pour conclure ce débrief on va rejoindre
à nouveau et steve jourdain dans
l'hémicycle pour parler et bien d'un
tout autre sujet qui a marqué bien le
début de la séance
puisqu'il ya aussi une question
consacrée à la crise libanaise et une
réponse assez forte
les ministres de l'europe et des
affaires étrangères jean yves le drian
la crise libanaise wii qui s'invitent
cette après midi dans l'émission qu'il
faut rappeler un que le liban traverse
actuellement une crise sans précédent
c'est une triple crise est une crise
politique économique une crise aussi
sanitaire le pays n'a pas de
gouvernement officiel ans depuis le mois
d'octobre l'actuel premier ministre saad
hariri et bien ne parvient pas à réunir
autour de sa personne et différentes
forces politiques libanaises et dans ce
contexte et bien emmanuel macron avait
proposé on s'en souvient au mois de
septembre une feuille de route
différentes forces politiques pour
l'heure est bien cette feuille de route
est bien et très largement resté lettre
morte
jean yves le drian vous l'avais dit à
mme est revenu sur cette crise et il a
solennellement mis en garde écoutez le
cette crise a des responsables bien
identifier leur aveuglement est un crime
de non assistance à pays en danger
l'obstruction délibéré à toute
perspective de sortie de crise est en
partie
[Musique]